Some trips are just better in an Airbnb. And right now, you can discover Canada and there are many local hidden gems with an Airbnb. I worked in Canada off and on for two years. Yes. And my first year, the production put me up at a place. And the second year, I was like, hey, whatever that production budget is, can I have it and go find my own place? And like more of a neighborhood, you know? Yes.
有些旅行住Airbnb会更好。现在，你可以通过Airbnb探索加拿大，发现许多当地隐藏的瑰宝。我在加拿大断断续续工作了两年。是的。第一年，剧组给我安排了住处。第二年，我就想，嘿，不管那笔制作预算是多少，我能拿去自己找住处吗？找个更有社区氛围的地方，你知道吗？是的。
And I did. I got an Airbnb. I got a little apartment. It faced a park. It was so lovely. I loved the host. And I stayed there for two months. Wow. Yeah. And I was near a grocery store. I really felt like I made a little life there. I'm thinking about like the Rocky Mountain areas in Canada where they've got the lakes and the Alberta Rockies. I don't know. It just feels like if you got yourself a cozy little cabin there, you know what I mean? Yeah. like Banff National Park.
我确实这么做了。我租了一间Airbnb。那是一个小公寓，正对着公园。非常可爱。我很喜欢房东。我在那里住了两个月。哇。是的。而且离杂货店很近。我真的感觉在那里过上了一种小生活。我在想加拿大落基山脉那些有湖泊的地方，还有阿尔伯塔省的落基山脉。我不知道。感觉如果你在那里给自己找个舒适的小木屋，你懂我的意思吗？是的，比如班夫国家公园。
Well, listen, maybe you should consider Airbnb for your next adventure. I mean, we love it. Love it. Hey, everyone. Welcome to the second drink of product recall. This was our 50th Office Ladies episode Breakdown. Those early milestones were always so big to me. I remember thinking, oh, my God, we've done 50 of these.
好吧，听着，也许你应该考虑在下一次冒险中选择Airbnb。我是说，我们很喜欢它。非常喜欢。嘿，大家好。欢迎来到《产品召回》的第二部分。这是我们《办公室女士》剧集解析的第50集。那些早期的里程碑对我来说总是意义重大。我记得当时想，天哪，我们已经做了50集了。
Yeah. And this episode had great behind-the-scenes details from co-writers Brent Forrester and Justin Spitzer. Plus, we got some on-set memories from guest star Shira Scott Astroff. You know, she played Jamie in those scenes at the high school. And, you know, this episode has some of the office fans' favorite quotes. We discussed a few of them, but according to the internet, as you like to say, Angela, there are four quotes that make the lists every time and they are all in product recall. Here's what they are.
是的。这一集有来自联合编剧布伦特·福雷斯特和贾斯汀·斯皮策的精彩幕后细节。此外，我们还有客串明星希拉·斯科特·阿斯特罗夫提供的片场回忆。你知道，她在高中那些场景里扮演杰米。而且，你知道，这一集里有《办公室》粉丝最喜欢的一些名言。我们讨论了其中几句，但根据互联网的说法，安吉拉，正如你喜欢说的那样，有四句名言每次都会上榜，而且它们都在《产品召回》这一集里。它们是这些。
Number one. Fact. Bears eat beats. Bears beats Battlestar Galactica. Yep. Identity theft is not a joke, Jim. Millions of families suffer every year. Lord, bear me strength. One of my favorites. And from you, Angela, I don't have a headache. I'm just preparing. That is a meme. I get sent. I mean, all four of those are in this episode. I know. Wild. You know, there are also some really good lines in the deluxe. scenes and the candy bag alts, too. I thought we could dive into some, and I wanted to start with this Kelly Angela Runner. We mentioned it in our breakdown, but we didn't play any of it. We talk about the big fight they have because Angela is horrible at customer service, and Kelly gets
第一名。事实。熊吃甜菜。熊、甜菜、太空堡垒卡拉狄加。没错。身份盗用不是开玩笑的，吉姆。每年有数百万家庭深受其害。上帝啊，赐予我力量吧。我最喜欢的名言之一。还有你说的，安吉拉，“我没有头痛。我只是在做准备。”那是一个表情包。我经常收到。我是说，这四句都在这一集里。我知道。太疯狂了。你知道，在豪华版场景和糖果袋备选台词里也有一些非常好的台词。我想我们可以深入探讨一下，我想从凯利和安吉拉的这段对手戏开始。我们在解析中提到了它，但没有播放任何片段。我们谈论了她们之间的大争吵，因为安吉拉的客户服务做得太糟糕了，凯利感到
frustrated and tells Angela she looks old enough to be her mother, and Angela gets really pissed off. She storms off. In a deleted scene, Kelly apologizes to Angela, hoping that Angela will then also apologize for her snarky comments. and deleted scenes, so Kelly comes over to accounting. Hey, Angela, I'm sorry that I said that you were old enough to be my mother. I don't know why I said that. I think I might be hypoglycemic or something, but still, it's no excuse. So I'm very sorry.
很沮丧，告诉安吉拉她看起来老得足以当她妈妈了，安吉拉气坏了。她冲了出去。在一个删减片段中，凯利向安吉拉道歉，希望安吉拉也能为她尖酸刻薄的评论道歉。在删减片段里，凯利来到会计部。嘿，安吉拉，我很抱歉说你老得足以当我妈妈。我不知道我为什么要那么说。我想我可能是低血糖什么的，但无论如何，这不是借口。所以我真的很抱歉。
Oh. Thank you, Kelly. And I wish I hadn't called you stupid. Do you think I'm a sled? No, but some of your outfits are not... I didn't apologize. We're like best friends now. We're not.
哦。谢谢你，凯利。我也希望我没叫你蠢货。你觉得我是个雪橇吗？不，但你的一些装扮不是……我没道歉。我们现在就像最好的朋友了。我们不是。
I'll text you. Don't. Bye, Angela. Fine. Does Kelly really think they're going to be pals? I mean, this is... If Kelly is being sincere, I can see why her and Ryan have lasted so long. It doesn't take much to win back her favor.
我会给你发短信的。别发。再见，安吉拉。好吧。凯利真的以为她们会成为好朋友吗？我是说，这……如果凯利是真心的，我能理解为什么她和瑞恩能维持这么久。赢得她的好感并不需要太多努力。
I mean, Angela really doesn't apologize at all. But Kelly is just so, you know, Delighted. She's pleased. This would have cut to an Angela talking head. It's also in deleted scenes, but I wanted to read you the scripted version and then a few candy bag alts. All right. Angela, Kelly's not so bad.
我是说，安吉拉根本就没有道歉。但凯利只是，你知道，很高兴。她很满意。这本该切到一个安吉拉的访谈镜头。它也在删减片段里，但我读一下剧本版本，然后再读几个糖果袋备选台词。好的。安吉拉，凯利没那么坏。
She really taught me something today. Can you tell that I'm still lying? Here's another one. I never lie, but I will fake like a melon plucker. I have never heard that. Mellon plucker. Yep. Lastly, yes, Kelly apologize for her comments.
她今天真的教了我一些东西。你能看出我还在撒谎吗？这是另一个。我从不撒谎，但我会像个摘瓜人一样假装。我从没听过这个。摘瓜人。没错。最后，是的，凯利为她的评论道歉了。
And I forgave her, but do I no longer hate Kelly? No, I still hate Kelly. But knowing she was sorry makes me hate her just a little bit less. Oh, okay. There you go. Maybe that's the one Kelly really hopes for, that Angela hates her just a little bit less. Well, I know you dug into the candy bag alts for Kelly and Angela, but guess what? I dove into the candy bag alts for Kevin.
我原谅了她，但我不再讨厌凯利了吗？不，我还是讨厌凯利。但知道她感到抱歉让我讨厌她的程度稍微减轻了一点点。哦，好吧。就是这样。也许这就是凯利真正希望的，安吉拉讨厌她稍微少一点点。好吧，我知道你钻研了凯利和安吉拉的糖果袋备选台词，但你猜怎么着？我钻研了凯文的糖果袋备选台词。
There are just so many treasures. In this candy bag, I found a Kevin talking head to share that made me laugh so hard. So remember when Kevin is sassy to Angela because she's having a tough time with the customer service line? And he just couldn't wait to make a snarky comment about it. And then he and Oscar do their little high five. Yeah. Well, there was a talking head for him in the candy bag where we learned that he has been holding on to some resentment toward Angela. And here's how it read.
这个糖果袋里有太多宝藏了。我发现了一个凯文的访谈镜头，让我笑得不行。还记得凯文对安吉拉说风凉话，因为她在处理客户服务热线时遇到了困难吗？他简直迫不及待地想对此发表尖酸刻薄的评论。然后他和奥斯卡击了个掌。是的。好吧，糖果袋里有一个他的访谈镜头，我们了解到他一直对安吉拉怀恨在心。内容是这样的。
Angela caught me counting on my fingers one time and she made my life hell. Well, today, I will make her life hell four, that it says counting on fingers to four, then, four hours. It's such classic Kevin. Well, there are just so many great one-liners in this episode from our amazing writers. We were so blessed. We really were. All right, before we break down product recall, I have to tell you,
安吉拉有一次抓到我在用手指计数，她让我的生活变成了地狱。好吧，今天，我会让她的生活变成地狱，四，上面写着数手指到四，然后，四个小时。这真是典型的凯文。好吧，这一集里有太多来自我们出色编剧的精彩台词了。我们真的很幸运。我们确实很幸运。好了，在解析《产品召回》之前，我必须告诉你，
I couldn't help but think of this lazy genius episode. You guys know lazy genius is on our Office Ladies Network. Kendra Adachi, amazing host, and she has an episode called How to Handle Bad Moods. And I thought about Angela Martin a lot when I was hearing it because she's so grumpy in this episode. She does not want to work with Kelly Kippur. Kendra, she could have used that episode. She has seven things she reminds you of when it comes to handling bad moods. And let me tell you, Angela Martin.
我不禁想起了这一集《懒人天才》。你们知道《懒人天才》在我们《办公室女士》网络频道上。肯德拉·阿达奇，很棒的主持人，她有一集叫《如何处理坏情绪》。我在听的时候想到了很多安吉拉·马丁，因为她在这一集里脾气太坏了。她不想和凯利·卡普尔一起工作。肯德拉，她本可以用上那一集的。她有七件事可以提醒你如何处理坏情绪。让我告诉你，安吉拉·马丁。
would have needed all seven of those reminders. Anyway, it's a really great listen. Kendra, I loved it. Okay, let's get to Product Recall. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends.
会需要那七个提醒中的每一个。总之，这真的很值得一听。肯德拉，我喜欢它。好了，让我们进入《产品召回》。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。
And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the Office, ladies. Howdy, Ange. Bonjour, Jenna. Oh, that's going to kind of come up later in this episode. There's going to be some accents later.
现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。你好啊，安吉。Bonjour，珍娜。哦，这一集后面会提到这个。后面会有一些口音。
There are. Oh, it's fun accent day. Oh, no. People are turning us off. No, no, no. They're like, oh, no, it's accent day. Guys, it's okay. We won't go crazy.
确实会有。哦，这是有趣的口音日。哦，不。人们要关掉我们了。不，不，不。他们会说，哦，不，今天是口音日。伙计们，没关系。我们不会发疯的。
Yeah, this is a fun one, Jenna. Tell them what we're doing today. We are doing Product Recall, Season 3, Episode 20, written by Justin Spitzer and Brent Forrester and directed by Randall Einhorn. Randall, I was so excited when Randall got to direct. We'll get into that, but you know, Randall was our cinematographer, so this was really fun for him and fun for us. Did you know that Randall directed the most episodes of The Office? No, I did not. Crazy, right? I think he did 15. That is so wild. Well, I love that even more. Well, I am ready for a summary, Angela, but I've got a little special
是的，这一集很有趣，珍娜。告诉他们我们今天要做什么。我们要解析《产品召回》，第三季第20集，由贾斯汀·斯皮策和布伦特·福雷斯特编剧，兰德尔·艾因霍恩执导。兰德尔，当兰德尔能执导时我太兴奋了。我们会深入探讨这一点，但你知道，兰德尔是我们的摄影指导，所以这对他是件乐事，对我们也很有趣。你知道兰德尔执导了《办公室》最多的集数吗？不，我不知道。太疯狂了，对吧？我想他拍了15集。太狂野了。好吧，我更喜欢这一点了。好吧，我准备好听总结了，安吉拉，但我有一个特别的
something. Sam? It's Angela and Jenna Heudeau-W-W-A-W-E-W-E. What? Where is that from? That is so adorable. Isn't that so cool? It's so cute. That was sent in by Joey Mosecica, and he said he recorded all of the parts himself, just like Andy. I was going to ask, because there's like a doo-wap part. That's so cool. Thank you, Joey. All right, so here is the summary for product recall. Dunder Mifflin is in crisis mode after paper with an obscene watermark goes into circulation to customers. Oof. Michael organizes a press conference and apologizes to a client. When the client demands that Michael be fired, Michael recruits Pam and Dwight to help him make an apology video.
东西。萨姆？是安吉拉和珍娜的嘟哇声。什么？那是从哪来的？太可爱了。不是很酷吗？太可爱了。这是乔伊·莫塞西卡寄来的，他说他自己录了所有的部分，就像安迪一样。我正想问，因为里面有个嘟哇部分。太酷了。谢谢你，乔伊。好了，这是《产品召回》的总结。邓德·米夫林陷入了危机模式，因为印有淫秽水印的纸张流向了客户。哎哟。迈克尔组织了一场新闻发布会并向客户道歉。当客户要求解雇迈克尔时，迈克尔招募了帕姆和德怀特来帮他制作道歉视频。
The accountants learn how to make customer service. calls from Kelly, and Creed, who is determined to save his job, pins the blame on an employee at the paper mill. Poor Debbie Brown. Oh, poor Debbie. This was such a fun episode. I loved rewatching it. I had so many fun memories.
会计们向凯利学习如何接听客户服务电话，而决心保住工作的克里德将责任推卸给造纸厂的一名员工。可怜的黛比·布朗。哦，可怜的黛比。这一集太有趣了。我重温得很开心。我有太多有趣的回忆了。
Same. Oh, my gosh. I feel like Steve is in rare form in this episode. I also personally think some of the best quotes of the whole season three are in this episode. Oh, yes. It's so many. We'll get to it.
我也是。天哪。我觉得史蒂夫在这一集里的状态非常罕见。我也个人认为整个第三季中一些最好的名言都在这一集里。哦，是的。太多了。我们会讲到的。
And I just want to share one of my favorite quotes of the whole entire series is in this episode. Oh. This is also the episode of animal noises or nonverbal reactions. Yeah. Accents and nonverbals. Someone just hit fast forward. Oh, no. Well, fast fact number one, I mentioned that this episode was written by both Justin Spitzer and Brent Forrester.
我只想分享我整个系列中最喜欢的名言之一就在这一集里。哦。这一集也是动物叫声或非语言反应的一集。是的。口音和非语言。有人刚刚按了快进。哦，不。好吧，第一个快速事实，我提到这一集是由贾斯汀·斯皮策和布伦特·福雷斯特共同编剧的。
I should probably clarify that there are some writers who work in teams. Yes. Like we've mentioned before, Gene and Lee. They were a writing team. They were hired together as a duo. But Justin and Brent were not a writing team. They were hired separately. So this was interesting that they were co-writing this together.
我应该澄清一下，有些编剧是团队合作的。是的。就像我们之前提到的，吉恩和李。他们是一个写作团队。他们是作为二人组一起被雇佣的。但贾斯汀和布伦特不是一个写作团队。他们是分开雇佣的。所以这很有趣，他们竟然共同编剧了这一集。
Well, we reached out to both of them to hear what it was like to be paired together on this episode. So they said that Greg just paired them together because he thought it would be kind of fun. And Justin told me that they basically just split it down the middle, that Brent took a pass at Act 1, Justin did Act 2, and then they split Act 3. And then they came together one afternoon and they kind of went over it. And since Brent was the senior writer, he kind of took the lead on a kind of a dual rewrite. And then they turned it in and it was kind of, you know, punched up by the staff like every other episode. I could see Greg doing this because he loved pairing together people to see what would come out of that pairing, whether it was characters or writers. You know, he loved to see what happened. Even our
好吧，我们联系了他们两人，想听听在这集里被配对在一起是什么感觉。他们说格雷格只是把他们配在一起，因为他觉得这会很有趣。贾斯汀告诉我，他们基本上就是平分了工作，布伦特负责第一幕，贾斯汀负责第二幕，然后他们平分了第三幕。然后他们在一个下午聚在一起，过了一遍。由于布伦特是资深编剧，他在某种程度上主导了双重重写。然后他们交稿，就像其他每一集一样，由工作人员进行了润色。我能看出格雷格会这么做，因为他喜欢把人配对在一起，看看这种配对会产生什么，无论是角色还是编剧。你知道，他喜欢看会发生什么。甚至我们的
editors sometimes were paired up in different ways. Well, Brent said that it's true that Greg did make it clear that he was the senior writer and that he had final decision on what went into the draft, but he said right from the start, he could see that Justin's scenes were just so good that it would be a terrible mistake to put, quote, my grubby fingers on any of it, end quote. So he said that they didn't change any of each other's work. They ended up turning it in just as they had both originally written it. Well, that is so fun. All right, fast fact number two, I asked these guys, what was the inspiration for this episode? Was this based on anything in real life? And Justin told me that he couldn't remember exactly where the idea came from, but he's pretty sure that it just came out of one of those pitch sessions in the room.
剪辑师有时也会以不同的方式配对。好吧，布伦特说，格雷格确实明确表示他是资深编剧，并且对草稿的内容拥有最终决定权，这是真的，但他从一开始就看出贾斯汀的场景写得太好了，如果把“我的脏手”放在上面，那将是一个可怕的错误。所以他说他们没有改变对方的任何工作。他们最终交出的稿子和他们最初写的一模一样。好吧，那太有趣了。好了，第二个快速事实，我问这些人，这一集的灵感是什么？这是基于现实生活中的任何事情吗？贾斯汀告诉我，他不记得这个想法确切是从哪里来的，但他很确定它只是来自房间里的那些头脑风暴会议之一。
So it wasn't like one writer had the idea, but it was sort of a collective, one of your group mind things, Ange. Oh, I like group mind. Well, he said he does have a very distinct memory as they were circling closer and closer to something that felt like an episode. Lee Eisenberg suddenly blurted out a product recall. It's a product recall. And after Lee said that, they knew it was going to be like a defective product and a mini scandal. But here's the thing, Ang, here is why I asked.
所以并不是某个编剧有了这个想法，而是某种集体创作，你们那种群体思维的东西之一，安吉。哦，我喜欢群体思维。好吧，他说他有一个非常清晰的记忆，当他们越来越接近某种感觉像一集的东西时，李·艾森伯格突然脱口而出“产品召回”。这是一个产品召回。在李说了之后，他们就知道这将是一个关于缺陷产品和小型丑闻的故事。但问题是，安吉，这就是我问的原因。
I did a little Googling. This episode aired in April 2007, and the crazy thing is that in August of 2007, there was a massive, historic Mattel toy recall. A huge product recall. What did they recall? They recalled 19 million toys. What was it? Some of them were recalled because they had lead paint. Was it a GI Joe?
我稍微谷歌了一下。这一集在2007年4月播出，疯狂的是，在2007年8月，发生了一次大规模、历史性的美泰玩具召回事件。一次巨大的产品召回。他们召回了什么？他们召回了1900万件玩具。是什么？其中一些被召回是因为它们含有铅漆。是特种部队吗？
No, I don't know what it was. A bunch of toys that were shown to have lead paint. And the other was because there was a tiny magnet that kept falling off and it posed a choking hazard. But also in 2007, there was a massive crib recall. One million Greco and simplicity cribs were recalled. and I even read an article that called 2007, quote, the year of the recall. Well, that's crazy. I wonder if it was in the zeitgeist.
不，我不知道那是什么。一堆被证明含有铅漆的玩具。另一个是因为有一个小磁铁不断掉落，造成了窒息危险。但同样在2007年，发生了一次大规模的婴儿床召回。100万张Graco和Simplicity婴儿床被召回。我甚至读到一篇文章称2007年为“召回之年”。好吧，那太疯狂了。我想知道它是否在时代精神中。
It was in the group mind of the world. And it went into Lee's brain and he shouted it into the writer's room. And it became an episode of the office. Major group mind. That's some global group mind. Okay, lady, I'm going to move us along to fast fact number three. I'm calling it location alert. Okay.
它在世界的群体思维中。它进入了李的大脑，他把它喊进了编剧室。它就成了《办公室》的一集。重大的群体思维。那是一些全球性的群体思维。好了，女士，我要带我们进入第三个快速事实。我称之为地点警报。好的。
As part of this episode, Jim and Andy go to a local high school to apologize for the obscene watermark. And Kentapedia let us know, because we got some mail. People wanted to know, was this the same school where we shot DeWali? People love to know about locations. They love it. This was filmed at a different school than DeWalli. This time we filmed at St. John Paul Academy in Burbank. In real life, it is a private Catholic STEM.
作为这一集的一部分，吉姆和安迪去了一所当地高中，为淫秽水印道歉。肯塔百科让我们知道，因为我们收到了一些邮件。人们想知道，这是我们拍摄《排灯节》的那所学校吗？人们喜欢了解地点。他们很喜欢。这次拍摄的学校和《排灯节》不同。这次我们在伯班克的圣约翰保罗学院拍摄。在现实生活中，它是一所私立天主教STEM
immersion high school. The school colors are white, blue, and red, and the real students at the school wear uniforms. For our shoot, we hired background performers to play the students. We did not use the actual students of this school. I feel like that is a thorough answer to this location question. Yeah. You know, I went to a Catholic high school. It was not co-ed. It was all girls, and I wore a uniform, and our colors were green and white and gray and navy. I think we're the colors we were allowed to wear and yellow. That's a lot of colors. It's really only five and you're only allowed to wear those colors.
沉浸式高中。学校的颜色是白色、蓝色和红色，学校里的真实学生穿制服。为了拍摄，我们雇佣了背景演员来扮演学生。我们没有使用这所学校的真实学生。我觉得这是一个对地点问题的详尽回答。是的。你知道，我上过一所天主教高中。它不是男女同校的。全是女生，我穿制服，我们的颜色是绿色、白色、灰色和海军蓝。我想我们被允许穿的颜色还有黄色。那颜色太多了。其实只有五种，而且你只被允许穿那些颜色。
Seems like a lot. Let's kill it back. Do you wear? How many colors do you wear? I just grab whatever's, you know, there. Right. So imagine you're getting dressed in the morning and you have to limit it. to only these five colors.
看起来很多。让我们切回来。你穿什么？你穿多少种颜色？我只是随便抓起手边的东西，你知道。对。所以想象一下你早上穿衣服，你必须限制它。只能穿这五种颜色。
Well, listen, a friend of mine did that thing. Remember when ladies would get their colors done? Oh, yes. And you find out if you're like fall or spring. A summer or a winter or something. My mom did this. My mom was a summer. Okay.
好吧，听着，我的一个朋友做了那件事。还记得女士们会去做色彩测试吗？哦，是的。你会发现你是秋季型还是春季型。夏季型或冬季型什么的。我妈妈做过这个。我妈妈是夏季型。好的。
So a friend of mine recently did this. Wait, they're still doing this? They're still doing it. It sort of went out of fashion, but whatever. She did it. And she found out that she's like shades of blue and coral and white. And she just filled her closet with those colors. She's always in those three colors.
所以我的一个朋友最近做了这个。等等，他们还在做这个？他们还在做。它有点过时了，但无所谓。她做了。她发现她是蓝色、珊瑚色和白色的色调。她就把她的衣柜填满了这些颜色。她总是穿那三种颜色。
So do you know what she is? Is that summer? I don't know. Blue and white? I don't know what it is. Maybe spring. But listen, it's a commitment to stay in those three colors. I'd have a hard time.
你知道她是什么吗？是夏天吗？我不知道。蓝色和白色？我不知道那是什么。也许是春天。但听着，坚持只穿那三种颜色是一种承诺。我会觉得很难。
Oh my gosh. This is literally what I was saying. I said I could only wear five colors. And you're like, it's a lot of colors. I don't see what the issue is. And now you're like, I would have a hard time only wearing a few colors. My point was, if you're going to have a school that has uniforms, you can't have a lot of options. Why?
天哪。这简直就是我刚才说的。我说我只能穿五种颜色。然后你说，那颜色太多了。我不明白有什么问题。现在你又说，只穿几种颜色你会觉得很难。我的意思是，如果你要办一所要求穿校服的学校，你就不能提供太多选择。为什么？
Because you're already... You can't have personal expression within uniform? No. Oh, my gosh. You're taking a stand. You've clearly not thought about this at all because you are taking multiple positions on this one subject. What's the point of having a uniform if you can have multiple colors and freedom of expression? There's no point.
因为你已经……你不能在校服里表达个性吗？不能。天哪。你这是在表明立场。你显然根本没考虑过这个问题，因为你在这个问题上持多种立场。如果可以有多种颜色和表达自由，那穿校服还有什么意义？毫无意义。
Either have a uniform or don't. All right. Well, we had to all wear the same skirt. It was the same. There was no choice or navy pants. Or a yellow shirt or a green shirt or a white shirt. We have to be done talking about this. On top, you could wear the different colors.
要么穿校服，要么不穿。好吧。我们当时都得穿一样的裙子。是一样的。没得选，要么是海军蓝裤子。要么是黄衬衫、绿衬衫或白衬衫。我们得结束这个话题了。上衣你可以穿不同颜色的。
But they had to be a collared shirt and you couldn't have any logos. No logos. Not even like, you know, some people, they would try to sneak in like a little polo. on their lapel. And that would be a no. Wow. Lock it up. Lock it up, uniform. Lock it up. Lady, where are we? Well, we're ready to take a break. And then we're going to come back and break down this episode. Well, before we take a break, I want to just share one thing about this episode. Well, I'll just get to it. What is it? I had the hugest zit on my cheek. I remember being really bummed out because I had a nice big storyline and I woke up with an enormous
但必须是有领衬衫，而且不能有任何标志。没有标志。甚至连那种，你知道，有些人会试图偷偷在翻领上弄个小马球标志。那是不行的。哇。锁起来。锁起来，校服。锁起来。女士，我们在哪儿？好吧，我们准备休息一下。然后回来解析这一集。好吧，在休息之前，我想分享关于这一集的一件事。好吧，我直接说吧。是什么？我脸颊上长了个巨大的痘痘。我记得当时真的很沮丧，因为我有一个很棒的大剧情，结果醒来时脸上长了一个巨大的
sit on my cheek and they tried to cover it with makeup. Jenna, they didn't splurge for CGI and scochy it out. It's in the whole episode. There's so much makeup on it. It's like an orange patch on my cheek. I did not notice it one time. It's on my left cheek. Do you have time codes for it? Is that something we can look forward to after the break? Yes. Yes. Well, there you go. If you want to close up. Well, listen. I'm sure you're riveted now. You can't wait to come back. We're going to take a break. Come back with this episode. With Amex Platinum, access to exclusive Amex pre-sale tickets can score you a spot trackside.
痘痘，他们试图用化妆品遮住它。珍娜，他们没有花钱做CGI把它修掉。整集都有它。上面涂了厚厚的粉底。就像我脸颊上的一块橙色斑块。我一次都没注意到。它在我的左脸颊上。你有时间码吗？这是我们休息后可以期待的内容吗？是的。是的。好吧，给你。如果你想看特写的话。好吧，听着。我相信你现在一定被吸引住了。你一定迫不及待想回来了。我们要休息一下。回来继续讲这一集。有了美国运通白金卡，获得独家美国运通预售门票，就能让你在赛道旁占有一席之地。
So being a fan for life turns into the trip of a lifetime. That's the powerful backing of Amex. Presale tickets for future events subject to availability and vary by race. Turns and conditions apply. Learn more at mx.ca.com. slash YNX. Fly Air Transat Seven time winners Champions
所以，成为终身粉丝就能变成一生难忘的旅行。这就是美国运通强大的后盾。未来活动的预售门票视供应情况而定，并因比赛而异。条款和条件适用。详情请访问 mx.ca.com 斜杠 YNX。乘坐加拿大越洋航空，七次获奖冠军
Fly the seven time world's best leisure airline champions Air Transat Okay so we start off this episode with a very funny cold open. I think it is one of the classics of all the cold opens on the whole series.
乘坐七次荣获世界最佳休闲航空公司冠军的加拿大越洋航空。好了，我们以一个非常有趣的开场白开始了这一集。我认为这是整个系列中最经典的开场白之一。
100%. It is Jim, dressed as Dwight, acting like Dwight, and it makes Dwight crazy in some of the best lines right here in this cold open. Lady, I remember filming this episode, and John Krasinski was so funny. We could not hold it together. Well, we all knew how great he was at Impressions, and so when he got to actually flex that a little, we were just like, ah, I can't wait to watch. Well, Angela, I think this cold open has two of our most quoted. moments. For sure. Number one, bears beats Battlestar Galactica. I mean, how many t-shirts is that on? It's on everything. And also, identity theft is not a joke, Jim. Millions of families suffer
百分之百。那是吉姆，打扮成德怀特，表现得像德怀特，这让德怀特抓狂，在这个开场白里有一些最棒的台词。女士，我记得拍摄这一集时，约翰·卡拉辛斯基太搞笑了。我们简直无法忍受。好吧，我们都知道他模仿得有多好，所以当他真正能发挥一下时，我们就像，啊，我迫不及待想看了。好吧，安吉拉，我认为这个开场白有两个我们被引用最多的时刻。肯定的。第一，熊、甜菜、太空堡垒卡拉狄加。我是说，这印在多少件T恤上？什么都有。还有，身份盗窃不是玩笑，吉姆。数百万家庭每年都在受苦
every year. That's right. I see that all the time. Identity theft is not a joke. Don't we sell pencils that say identity theft is not a joke? Don't we have a pencil pack on officeladys.com? Yes. And we have that quote, right? And we also have Bears Beats Battlestar Galactica. It's just one of my favorite quotes. It is not my favorite quote of the whole episode, though. We'll get to that. But this couplet is so fun. And I have seen people like at conventions and stuff say this, false, black bear. Like the whole thing. Oh yeah, let's, we should play it. Sam. Yeah, let's play this. Play this clip. Question. What kind of bear is best? That's a ridiculous question. False. Black Bear.
每年。没错。我经常看到这个。身份盗窃不是玩笑。我们不是卖印有“身份盗窃不是玩笑”的铅笔吗？我们 officeladys.com 上不是有铅笔套装吗？是的。我们有那句名言，对吧？我们还有“熊、甜菜、太空堡垒卡拉狄加”。这只是我最喜欢的这一集名言之一。不过，这不是我整集最喜欢的名言。我们稍后会讲到。但这段对白太有趣了。我见过人们在漫展之类的场合说这个，假的，黑熊。整个过程。哦，是的，我们应该播放它。萨姆。是的，播放这个。播放这个片段。问题。哪种熊最好？那是个荒谬的问题。假的。黑熊。
Well, that's debatable. There are basically two schools of thought. Fact. Bears eat beats. Bears beats Battlestar Galactica. Bears do not. What is going on? What are you doing?
嗯，那有待商榷。基本上有两种思想流派。事实。熊吃甜菜。熊、甜菜、太空堡垒卡拉狄加。熊不吃。怎么回事？你在干什么？
I love it so much. I want to know, what are the two schools of thoughts about bears? We never find out. We don't. Listen, we had a fan question from Ashley Trick, Emily Dennis, Faith L, Rianne Holb, and Terrib. LaPorte. Basically, they all said the same version of this. Please, please, please, tell us everything about the cold open. It is one of the best sequences on television ever. How long did it take John and Rain to get through it? Here's what I found out, Angela. Okay. Kentapedia thinks we only did about eight takes of this. He said it went a lot faster than we may realize. Well, it was a quick beat, you know? It was a quick scene. And then I asked Justin, and he said that he and Brent did not write this cold open. They wrote a cold open where Michael is getting scammed by a telemarketer.
我太喜欢了。我想知道，关于熊的两种思想流派是什么？我们永远不会知道。我们不知道。听着，我们收到了来自阿什利·特里克、艾米丽·丹尼斯、费思·L、里安·霍尔布和特里布·拉波特的粉丝提问。基本上，他们都说了这个问题的不同版本。求求你，求求你，告诉我们关于开场白的一切。这是电视史上最棒的片段之一。约翰和雷恩拍了多久才完成？我查到了，安吉拉。好吧。肯塔百科认为我们只拍了大约八次。他说这比我们意识到的要快得多。好吧，这是一个快速的节奏，你知道吗？这是一个快速的场景。然后我问了贾斯汀，他说他和布伦特并没有写这个开场白。他们写了一个迈克尔被电话推销员诈骗的开场白。
But during the rewriting process, Gene and Lee are the ones who came up with the idea for Jim to come in as Dwight. And they wrote the cold open. And it was Mike Shore who pitched the line Bears Beats Battlestar Galactica. applause applause this is why you need a whole writing team look at that that's how the magic happens it's a collaboration people
但在重写过程中，吉恩和李想出了让吉姆扮成德怀特的点子。他们写了这个开场白。是迈克·肖尔提出了“熊、甜菜、太空堡垒卡拉狄加”这句台词。鼓掌鼓掌，这就是为什么你需要整个编剧团队，看看吧，这就是魔法发生的方式，这是一个合作，伙计们。
I have two other observations about this cold open not as popular as the obvious ones bears beats Battlestar Galactica all that but I have you know there is a new plant at reception no get out of here What is going on? I am telling you, I don't know when I'll have time to do this, but I am going to
关于这个开场白，我还有两个观察，不像那些明显的那么受欢迎，比如“熊、甜菜、太空堡垒卡拉狄加”之类的，但我有，你知道，接待处有一株新植物，不，别开玩笑了，怎么回事？我告诉你，我不知道什么时候有时间做这件事，但我打算
screen grab every plant on reception for the whole series. What is it this week? It's a real sad looking plant. It's only got a few leaves on it. It's in a purple pot with, it looks like some polka dots. And it is through the whole episode. I notice it's in the cold open, the tag, and the whole episode. And in Jim's talking head where he says he created that whole look for $11.
把整个系列中接待处的每一株植物都截图下来。这周是什么？这是一株看起来很可怜的植物。它只有几片叶子。它在一个紫色的花盆里，看起来上面有一些波点。它贯穿了整集。我注意到它在开场白、片尾和整集中都有出现。还有在吉姆的采访中，他说他只花了11美元就创造了整个造型。
Yeah. We have an old tech alert. Old tech alert. We have the old calculator watch. Oh, yeah. Now, I know that Dwight always wears one, but just to see Jim actually use it, like you hear the beeping as he's adding on it. I just thought it was really fun. How often do you use the calculator on your phone?
是的。我们有旧科技警报。旧科技警报。我们有旧的计算器手表。哦，是的。现在，我知道德怀特总是戴着一块，但看到吉姆真的用它，就像你听到他在上面加法时的哔哔声。我只是觉得这真的很有趣。你多久用一次手机上的计算器？
Surprisingly a lot. Same. Same. I see why they made a calculator watch. Yeah. Because you, you know, I use it. I mean, I remember, like, because I'm 100 years old, that. You know, boys would have it at school and they would be told in math class, they could not use it.
出奇地多。我也是。我也是。我明白他们为什么要制造计算器手表了。是的，因为你，你知道，我用它。我是说，我记得，因为我已经100岁了，那个。你知道，男生在学校里会有这个，他们会被数学老师告知，他们不能使用它。
You know, I spent a year where I refused to let myself use a calculator and I had to do all of my math problems by hand. It was just a weird commitment I made to not, you know, I don't know. It was a weird commitment I made because I felt sort of like I should be able to add 26 and 97 without a calculator. Like just, you know, carry the one or whatever. And how old were you when you made this commitment? I was in my 30s. Really? Yeah.
你知道，我花了一年时间，拒绝让自己使用计算器，我必须手工完成所有的数学题。这只是我做的一个奇怪的承诺，不，你知道，我不知道。这是一个奇怪的承诺，因为我觉得我应该能够不使用计算器就算出26加97。就像，你知道，进位之类的。你做这个承诺时多大？我30多岁了。真的吗？是的。
I was really expecting you to say I was 24. No. I just got disappointed in myself for relying on my calculator for simple math problems. So did I know you when you made this commitment? Because I knew you in your 30s. Yeah. I guess you did. I guess I never added anything or subtractive.
我真的以为你会说我24岁。不。我只是对自己依赖计算器来做简单的数学题感到失望。那么我在你做这个承诺时认识你吗？因为我在你30多岁时认识你。是的。我想你认识。我想我从来没有在你面前加减过任何东西。
anything around you. My best friend in her 30s took a year off from calculators and didn't tell me. I do weird stuff like that sometimes. What is that about me? I think you like to make hurdles for yourself. What is this horrible? I just speak to a therapist about this. What am I doing? Why am I thinking my life harder? You get into a real cushy stride. You're like, hey, things are clipping along. I'm having a great run here. I'm going to give myself a hurdle. Yeah. I don't deserve. Too easy. I'm going to stop using a calculator. I don't deserve this because she's stride right now. I'm not allowed to use a calculator. Oh, my God. Lady. It's okay to use a calculator. Well, I use one now. I mean, that was one of the dumbest things I've ever done. That was one of my dumber goals. I'm sure there's
任何东西。我最好的朋友在她30多岁时停用了一年计算器，而且没告诉我。我有时会做那种奇怪的事情。我这是怎么了？我想你喜欢给自己设置障碍。这有什么可怕的？我刚和治疗师谈过这个。我在做什么？为什么我要让我的生活变得更难？你进入了一个非常舒适的节奏。你会觉得，嘿，事情进展得很顺利。我跑得很棒。我要给自己设个障碍。是的。我不配。太容易了。我要停止使用计算器。我不配拥有现在这种舒适的节奏。我不被允许使用计算器。天哪。女士。使用计算器没关系。好吧，我现在用一个。我是说，那是我做过的最愚蠢的事情之一。那是我比较愚蠢的目标之一。我相信肯定有
a mathematician out there somewhere that's like really into that, Jenna. It's like, yeah, way to go. You know what I'll say? At the end of the year, I was no better at adding, subtracting, or multiplying than I was when I started. You can't say that. That can't be your button. It wasn't. There was no skill gained. There was no speed. Nothing. I was still, you know, counting on my fingers to carry the numbers. I mean, it was like it was for nothing. thing. You just had a year where you were slightly more irritable. Okay, let's get into this episode. Speaking of people being irritable, everyone is on the phone with very upset customers. I want to share with you that there are a lot of delicious
某个数学家在那里，真的很喜欢那个，珍娜。就像，是的，干得好。你知道我会说什么吗？到年底，我在加减乘除方面并没有比开始时更好。你不能这么说。那不能作为你的结论。不是那样的。没有获得任何技能。没有速度。什么都没有。我仍然，你知道，用手指计数来进位。我是说，这就像是白费力气。你只是度过了一年，稍微变得更易怒了。好吧，让我们进入这一集。说到易怒的人，每个人都在电话里和非常愤怒的客户交谈。我想告诉你，有很多美味的
deleted scenes, and one of them starts off in customer service with this speech, and Kelly repeats it over and over, and Ryan is like dying. inside because he's right behind her, and then it cuts to a talking head of Ryan, and he's got it fully memorized. But this is what Kelly says, right at the top of the episode, had it stayed in. Customer service, this is Kelly. Oh, my God. I am so sorry. That is so messed up. Everyone here is so upset. You have no idea. And rest assured, your voice has been heard. Okay, I'll be thinking about you all day. Customer service, this is Kelly. Oh my God. I am so sorry. That is so messed up. Everyone here is so upset. You have no idea. And rest assured,
删减片段，其中一个片段以客服部门的这段演讲开始，凯利一遍又一遍地重复它，瑞安在里面快要死掉了，因为他就站在她身后，然后切到瑞安的采访，他已经完全背下来了。但这就是凯利在这一集开头说的话，如果它保留下来的话。客服，我是凯利。天哪。我太抱歉了。这太糟糕了。这里的每个人都非常沮丧。你根本不知道。请放心，你的声音已经被听到了。好的，我会整天想着你的。客服，我是凯利。天哪。我太抱歉了。这太糟糕了。这里的每个人都非常沮丧。你根本不知道。请放心，
your voice has been heard. Okay, I'll be thinking about you all day. Wow. She says it on a loop. And Brian looks like he wants to just explode. Well, Michael has a talking head where he explains what happened, why everyone is so upset, why everyone's on the phone. I guess a disgruntled employee sent out 500 boxes of their standard paper with a pornographic watermark of two cartoon characters engaging in a sex act. Yes, he said it's a, you know, beloved duck doing something to a mouse. Yeah. Now, was he talking about Daffy Duck and Mickey Mouse?
你的声音已经被听到了。好的，我会整天想着你的。哇。她循环播放。布莱恩看起来想直接爆炸。好吧，迈克尔有一个采访，他解释了发生了什么，为什么每个人都这么沮丧，为什么每个人都在打电话。我想是一个心怀不满的员工寄出了500箱他们的标准纸，上面有一个色情水印，是两个卡通人物在进行性行为。是的，他说这是一个，你知道，深受喜爱的鸭子在对一只老鼠做某事。是的。现在，他在说达菲鸭和米老鼠吗？
Because he says, never been a fan, not a fan. Well, I think he would be talking about Donald Duck and Mickey Mouse. Oh, yes. Because Daffy is part of the Bugs Bunny. Oh, I can't keep my duck straight. I just like the idea. I'm so sorry. But that is the quote of the day.
因为他说，从来都不是粉丝，不是粉丝。好吧，我想他应该是在说唐老鸭和米老鼠。哦，是的。因为达菲是兔八哥系列的一部分。哦，我分不清我的鸭子。我只是喜欢这个想法。我太抱歉了。但那是今天的名言。
Oh, I just can't keep my ducks straight. There's so many. There's so many. There's so many. Cartoon ducks. You can Scrooge McDuck. There's so many. But I love the idea.
哦，我就是分不清我的鸭子。有太多了。有太多了。有太多了。卡通鸭子。你可以有史高治·麦克达克。有太多了。但我喜欢这个想法。
It just makes me laugh that Michael, has never liked Mickey Mouse. I know. Not funny enough for him? I don't know. Not edgy enough. Not enough jokes. Well, Michael holds up the piece of paper to the light and shows the watermark.
迈克尔从来不喜欢米老鼠，这让我觉得很好笑。我知道。对他来说不够有趣？我不知道。不够前卫。笑话不够多。好吧，迈克尔把那张纸举到光下，展示了水印。
And guess who did a little bit of a deep dive on watermarks? You? Because it wasn't me. And we're only two people on this podcast. Sam, Cody? Anyone? No one? No.
猜猜谁对水印做了一点深入研究？你？因为不是我。我们这个播客只有两个人。萨姆，科迪？有人吗？没人吗？不。
It was me, folks. It was me. listen, I don't know if this is going to be interesting. I found it fascinating. I'll do a quick overview, okay? So we all know what a watermark is, right? A watermark is basically this image that's applied to a piece of paper, right? And you hold it up to the light and that's how you see it. The term watermark comes from the way these designs are created. It's during the wet paper stage of making paper, right? It's almost like a damp, I know it was really fascinating, a damp water spot. here's where it gets interesting. Ready? Yes. Did you know that watermarks were first introduced
是我，伙计们。是我。听着，我不知道这是否会很有趣。我觉得它很迷人。我做一个快速概述，好吗？所以我们都知道什么是水印，对吧？水印基本上是应用在纸上的一张图像，对吧？你把它举到光下，这就是你看到它的方式。水印这个词来源于这些图案的制作方式。它是在造纸的湿纸阶段，对吧？它几乎就像一个潮湿的，我知道这真的很迷人，一个潮湿的水渍。这里变得有趣了。准备好了吗？是的。你知道水印最早是在什么时候引入的吗？
in Fabriano, Italy, and 1282? Yes, I did. You did not. Of course, I did not know that. Why did I believe you? I wholeheartedly believed you. I think my delivery was very good. You're a very good actress. You should have won that Emmy that year. I was really mad. You didn't. I cursed on national television. Okay. So, and they're not really sure why exactly watermark started in Italy then. It could have been, you know, to show, like maybe it was the service of the king or to convey a secret message or prove authenticity of a message, right? But now, wait, they were deliberately invented. So one thing I'm curious about is that the watermark was not an accident that happened one day in the wet papermaking stage of paper making. And then people were like,
在意大利法布里亚诺，1282年？是的，我知道。你不知道。我当然不知道。我为什么要相信你？我全心全意地相信你。我想我的表达非常好。你是一位非常出色的女演员。你那年应该赢得艾美奖的。我真的很生气。你没有。我在全国电视上骂人了。好吧。所以，他们并不确定水印到底为什么在那时在意大利开始。可能是，你知道，为了展示，也许是国王的服务，或者传达秘密信息，或者证明信息的真实性，对吧？但现在，等等，它们是故意发明的。所以有一件事我很好奇，水印不是某天在造纸的湿纸阶段发生的意外。然后人们就像，
my gosh, what if we did this on purpose? Someone purposely watermarked. Well, Jenna, I don't, I don't have, you know, the fellow's journal from 1282. It might have been a thing where he was like, hey, that's my thumb. Hey, that's cool. We should do that. Oh, I bet the king would like this, because then everyone would know it's his paper. I love how this, I love how this paper maker in Italy in the 1200s journals exactly like you. Exactly. Oh my God. My thumb. Oh, Hey, I should tell the king about this. He might like to have his official paper. Oh, man, going to have a glass of wine.
天哪，如果我们故意这样做会怎样？有人故意加了水印。好吧，珍娜，我没有，你知道，那个家伙1282年的日记。可能是一件事，他就像，嘿，那是我的拇指。嘿，那很酷。我们应该那样做。哦，我打赌国王会喜欢这个，因为那样每个人都会知道这是他的纸。我喜欢这个意大利1200年代的造纸工像你一样写日记。完全一样。哦，天哪。我的拇指。哦，嘿，我应该告诉国王这件事。他可能喜欢有他的官方纸。哦，伙计，去喝杯红酒。
Okay. Oh, look at the hummingbirds, Exo. Xo Xo Xo's paper maker guy. Smiley face. So, Cartier, Miliani, Fabriano claims to have innovated three techniques, which are still a part of paper making today. But here's the fun part, Jenna. Put this on our bucket list. you and I can go and visit the Paper and Watermark Museum of Fabriano in Italy.
好吧。哦，看那些蜂鸟，Xo。Xo Xo Xo的造纸工家伙。笑脸。所以，卡蒂埃，米利亚尼，法布里亚诺声称创新了三种技术，这些技术至今仍是造纸的一部分。但有趣的部分来了，珍娜。把它列入我们的愿望清单。你和我可以去参观意大利法布里亚诺的纸张和水印博物馆。
Oh, that is 100% happening now. How much fun would we have walking through that, getting a tour? How perfect would it be these two people who are on a show about paper going to one of the oldest paper mills in the world? I can't wait. That is bucket list for sure. Let's get back. Well, let me tell you what Brent told me about this obscene watermark. Oh, yes. Let's hear it. Brent, our writer, told me that this watermark for our show was faithfully created by our
哦，那现在百分之百会发生。我们走过那里，参观一下会有多开心？这两个人参加一个关于纸的节目，去世界上最古老的造纸厂之一，这该有多完美？我迫不及待了。那绝对是愿望清单。让我们回来。好吧，让我告诉你布伦特关于这个淫秽水印告诉我的事。哦，是的。让我们听听。布伦特，我们的编剧，告诉我这个节目的水印是由我们的
prop department and that it really did look like a blank sheet of paper. But when you get up close, you can see this little caricature. And he said after the episode, he asked the prop department to have one of the sheets of paper and he framed it and it hangs on the wall of his office. And he says, people come in all the time and they say, why do you have a blank piece of paper framed on your wall? And he says, it's a keepsake from the office, look closely. And then they lean forward and they inevitably say, oh, my God.
道具部门忠实地制作的，它看起来确实像一张白纸。但当你近看时，你可以看到这个小漫画。他说在这一集之后，他让道具部门给他一张纸，他把它装裱起来，挂在他办公室的墙上。他说，人们经常进来，他们说，为什么你的墙上挂着一张空白的纸？他说，这是来自办公室的纪念品，仔细看。然后他们向前倾，他们不可避免地说，哦，天哪。
Because, you know, on the show, we put the little black bar up to hide the real obscene part. But on the actual piece of paper, I think. It's there. It's all there. Yeah. There you go. And that was Phil Shea job that week. That was his job.
因为，你知道，在节目中，我们放了小黑条来隐藏真正的淫秽部分。但在实际的纸上，我想。它就在那里。都在那里。是的。给你。那是菲尔·谢伊那周的工作。那是他的工作。
How was your day? Well, I had to have a duck and a mouse, do some stuff. Anyway, how was your day? Exactly. I want to point out something before we get too far. Remember we said at the very beginning of this episode, everybody's on the phone and they're talking to customers and they're like really trying to do damage control. I wanted to point out that at one minute, 55 seconds, Creed is holding the phone up to his ear. but he isn't saying anything.
你今天过得怎么样？嗯，我得去弄只鸭子和一只老鼠，做点事情。总之，你今天过得怎么样？没错。在深入讨论之前，我想指出一点。还记得我们在这一集开头说的吗，每个人都在打电话，他们和客户交谈，真的在试图进行危机公关。我想指出，在1分55秒时，克里德把电话贴在耳边，但他什么也没说。
It's a little bit of foreshadowing, I think, for the fact that Creed knows he's responsible. He's just, he's pretending to be on the phone with a customer, I think, but not really. You could also just be Creed being Creed. Yeah. Not doing his job again. Exactly. So Michael gets everyone in the conference room. You know, this is like crunch time and he says Creed, you really messed up.
我认为这有点预示着克里德知道自己要负责任。我想他只是在假装和客户通电话，但其实并没有。你也可以说这就是克里德的本色。没错。又没在干活。没错。所以迈克尔把大家都叫到了会议室。你知道，这就像是关键时刻，他说克里德，你真的搞砸了。
Yeah. Quality assurance. So I feel like we officially hear Creed's job title. Quality Assurance. Creed says every week he's supposed to stop by the paper mill, give it a check. The one year he blew this off. So good. So he hasn't gone for a whole year.
是的。质量保证。所以我感觉我们正式听到了克里德的职位名称。质量保证。克里德说他每周都应该去造纸厂检查一下。这一年他没去。太棒了。所以他整整一年都没去。
Well, I know I said at the beginning of the podcast that Michael is in rare form in this episode, and he truly is in this conference room scene, but also Creed absolutely crushes it in this episode as well. he does so we get back into the conference room michael has just great stuff he's you know he was speaking in acronyms kremen squaw effancy not saving any time as everyone points out and he's really i mean michael's really freaking out he tells everyone this is threat level midnight yeah midnight oscar threat level midnight this is such a fun callback to the client yes and everybody gives little looks to each other because of it too Yeah.
嗯，我知道我在播客开头说过迈克尔在这一集中状态罕见，他在这个会议室场景中确实如此，但克里德在这一集中也表现得非常出色。他确实表现得很好，我们回到会议室，迈克尔的表现真是太棒了，你知道他一直在用缩写词，克里门、斯夸、埃凡西，正如大家指出的那样，这并没有节省任何时间，而且他真的，我是说迈克尔真的快疯了，他告诉大家这是“午夜威胁级别”。是的，午夜，奥斯卡，“午夜威胁级别”，这真是对《客户》那一集的有趣呼应。是的，每个人也都因此互相看了看。是的。
Well, then Michael says today, Kelly will be training everyone on how to do customer relations. And Angela, you have a talking head where you just take a pill and you say you don't have a headache. You're just preparing. Yeah. I loved this back-to-back talking heads because Mindy as Kelly is like, this day is bananas. B-A-N-A-S and she's so perky and happy, and then it cuts to me just taking an aspirin. Yeah. And my kids were really hung up on this.
嗯，然后迈克尔说今天凯利将培训大家如何处理客户关系。安吉拉，你有一个采访镜头，你只是吃了一片药，然后说你没有头痛。你只是在做准备。是的。我喜欢这些连续的采访镜头，因为明迪饰演的凯利说，这一天真是太疯狂了。B-A-N-A-N-A-S，她那么活泼快乐，然后镜头切到我只是在吃阿司匹林。是的。我的孩子们真的很纠结这一点。
They really wanted to know, was that a real pill? Did I have to take it? They were like, it looks like you take it. You swallow water. Oh, Angela, we got so much mail about this. Okay, Carlos L, Taya C, Emily W, Angela B, and Lily N all said, what did you take instead of a real pill? Well, I will tell you. I did a few takes of that talking head, and I had to take sugar pills.
他们真的很想知道，那是真药吗？我必须吃吗？他们说，看起来你真的吃了。你吞下了水。哦，安吉拉，我们收到了很多关于这个的邮件。好吧，卡洛斯·L、塔亚·C、艾米丽·W、安吉拉·B和莉莉·N都问，你吃了什么代替真药？好吧，我告诉你们。我拍了几个那个采访镜头的版本，我不得不吃糖丸。
Wow. So I guess that's a props thing. I've never had to take fake medicine on a show before, so that's weird. Yeah, Phil Shea brought it to me. He said, listen, it's just sugar. It's like a sugar pill. So you'll be totally fine. So I guess I just had a little spike in sugar that day.
哇。所以我猜那是道具。我以前在节目中从没吃过假药，所以这很奇怪。是的，菲尔·谢伊把它拿给我。他说，听着，这只是糖。就像糖丸。所以你完全没问题。所以我猜那天我的血糖稍微升高了一点。
So also during this conference room scene, Angela, we find out that Jim's client is a high school, and they printed their prom invitations on this paper. Yeah. So Michael tells Jim, he has to physically go to the high school to rectify the situation. He says, you have to bring someone. Ryan volunteers. Michael says, no, you have to bring Andy. William Doolittle, at your service, aka.
另外在这个会议室场景中，安吉拉，我们发现吉姆的客户是一所高中，他们把毕业舞会的邀请函印在了这种纸上。是的。所以迈克尔告诉吉姆，他必须亲自去高中纠正这种情况。他说，你必须带上某人。瑞安自告奋勇。迈克尔说，不，你必须带上安迪。威廉·杜利特尔，为您服务，又名。
We'll do. And there we go. We said we were going to bring you accents. We didn't lie. And Jim is like, yeah, I'm definitely going alone. And Michael's like, no, no, I need two men on this. That's what she said, no time, but she did. No time.
没问题。就这样。我们说过我们会给你们带来口音。我们没撒谎。吉姆说，是的，我肯定会一个人去。迈克尔说，不，不，我需要两个男人去处理这件事。那是她说的，没时间了，但她确实说了。没时间了。
That is like such fantastic dialogue. Is that your favorite quote? Is that the one? No. Still not yet. Still not yet. Well, I remember John could not keep it together in this conference room scene. And anytime John starts to laugh, it is a very bad sign for the rest of us because you just know that we're never going to make it
那真是太精彩的对话了。那是你最喜欢的台词吗？是那一句吗？不。还不是。还不是。嗯，我记得约翰在这个会议室场景中一直憋不住笑。每当约翰开始笑，对我们其他人来说就是一个非常糟糕的信号，因为你知道我们永远无法完成拍摄。
through. But Steve does something in this conference room scene that makes John Luce it. I'm going to guess. I have no idea what you're about to say. Okay. I know people can't see me, Jenna. Okay. Oh my God, Sam's filming. This is what Steve does at four minutes, two seconds, just to mess with all of us. Yep. There it is. Angela just put her foot up on the table and then leaned into her crotch. Do you know how hard it is to lift your head, leg this high when you're short? Like, that table's kind of high. Yeah.
但史蒂夫在这个会议室场景中做了一些让约翰崩溃的事情。我猜猜。我不知道你要说什么。好吧。我知道人们看不到我，珍娜。好吧。天哪，萨姆在拍摄。这就是史蒂夫在4分02秒时做的事情，只是为了捉弄我们所有人。是的。就在那儿。安吉拉刚才把脚放在桌子上，然后身体前倾靠向她的胯部。你知道当你个子矮的时候把腿抬这么高有多难吗？那张桌子有点高。是的。
Steve took his foot and he put it up on the conference table. And I remember the first take he decided to do that. John lost it. Yeah, because we had no idea. Anytime Steve did that. Steve used to do that to John's desk all the time. Yes, he would. And you know what, Jenna?
史蒂夫把脚抬起来放在会议桌上。我记得他第一次决定这样做时，约翰崩溃了。是的，因为我们根本不知道。每当史蒂夫那样做时。史蒂夫过去经常对约翰的桌子那样做。是的，他会。你知道吗，珍娜？
I remember in this scene when I lost it, I completely lost it when Michael goes, here is your headline. Scranton, area, paper company, Dunder Mifflin, apologizes to valued client. Some companies still know how business is done. That's what I'm saying. It's like, it's like the greatest hits of Michael in this one conference room scene. In this episode, it's so good. Well, now Michael reveals that he is invited.
我记得在这一幕中我崩溃了，当迈克尔说，“这是你们的头条新闻。斯克兰顿地区造纸公司邓德·米夫林向尊贵的客户道歉。有些公司仍然知道生意是怎么做的。”我就是这个意思。这就像是迈克尔在这一会议室场景中的精选集。在这一集中，真是太棒了。好吧，现在迈克尔透露他邀请了。
Barbara Allen, one of Dunder Mifflin's oldest customers into the office, he's going to offer her a personal apology. He says, if the press wants a story, we'll give him a story. Yeah, there's a great deleted scene of Dwight calling CNN. And like, no one will take his call. It's like, it's really funny. Oh my gosh. I love it. I love that Jim is like, did the press ask for a story? Nope. Nope. No. No. Michael explains in his talking head. When a company screws up, the best course of action is to hold a press conference. You got to control the spin. You got to control the story. Well, this had me look up crisis management, Angela, because that's a whole thing now. Now, I did a very shallow dive on it. All I found out was that this really became popular in like the 1980s. And this idea of getting ahead of the story is all part of the Crisis Management, Public Relations Handbook. So Michael has it a little bit right here, but he has it wrong in the sense that literally no one knows about this right now. Yeah.
芭芭拉·艾伦，邓德·米夫林最老的客户之一来到办公室，他要亲自向她道歉。他说，如果媒体想要故事，我们就给他们一个故事。是的，有一个很棒的删减片段是德怀特给CNN打电话。而且没人接他的电话。这真的很有趣。天哪。我喜欢它。我喜欢吉姆说，媒体要求故事了吗？没有。没有。没有。没有。迈克尔在采访镜头中解释说。当一家公司搞砸了，最好的行动方案就是召开新闻发布会。你必须控制舆论。你必须控制故事。好吧，这让我去查了危机管理，安吉拉，因为那现在是一门大学问。我对此做了一个非常浅显的研究。我只发现这在20世纪80年代左右才真正流行起来。这种抢在故事前面报道的想法都是危机管理、公共关系手册的一部分。所以迈克尔在这里有一点是对的，但他错在事实上现在根本没人知道这件事。是的。
If Michael had not made a big to-do, it would have just gone away. But no, he's going to blast it and it's going to blow up in his face. Yeah. So now we see Creed is trying to do his own kind of damage. control. I mean, Creed says that this job is the only thing separating him from being a homeless man because he was a homeless guy. Yeah. I have to say, Creed calling up this paper mill and asking who wasn't there last week so that he can then pin it on this employee is kind of genius. Oh, Creed's a survivor. I mean, he's smart. He's actually, he's very smart. He's cunning. He's
如果迈克尔没有大张旗鼓，这件事本来就会过去。但没有，他要把它闹大，结果会搬起石头砸自己的脚。是的。所以现在我们看到克里德正在试图进行他自己的危机公关。我是说，克里德说这份工作是他和流浪汉之间唯一的隔阂，因为他曾经是个流浪汉。是的。我不得不说，克里德打电话给造纸厂询问上周谁不在，以便他能把责任推给那个员工，这简直是天才。哦，克里德是个幸存者。我是说，他很聪明。他实际上，他非常聪明。他很狡猾。他
Yeah. I was actually impressed. Yeah. I was like, wow. Wowsers. Who thought of that? It's exactly how I got my internship on Conan O'Brien, by the way. Wait, what? You know this story. Oh, yeah. You called up and... I just kept... I would call and I would get like an answering machine, you know, because I wanted to do an internship at 30 Rock and in New York.
是的。我其实印象深刻。是的。我当时想，哇。太厉害了。谁想到的？顺便说一句，这正是我获得柯南·奥布莱恩实习机会的方式。等等，什么？你知道这个故事。哦，是的。你打电话，然后……我只是不断地……我会打电话，然后我会得到一个答录机，你知道，因为我想在纽约的30号洛克菲勒中心实习。
And back in the day before, like, big internet message boards and things like that, because I'm 100, you would have a phone number you would call. And I would say, hi, it would be like 30 Rockefeller Center. And I'd be like, hi, I would love to apply for an internship. Hold one moment, please. Transfer you to a machine. If you would like to apply for an internship at 30 Rockefeller Center, please leave your name and phone number and someone will call you. I got that message every day for three months. And so one day I called up, I got the woman in B.C., you know, 30 Rockefeller Center.
在那个没有大型互联网留言板之类的日子里，因为我100岁了，你会有一个要拨打的电话号码。我会说，嗨，就像是30号洛克菲勒中心。我会说，嗨，我想申请实习。请稍等。转接到机器。如果您想申请30号洛克菲勒中心的实习，请留下您的姓名和电话号码，会有人给您回电。我连续三个月每天都收到那个信息。所以有一天我打电话，我接通了B.C.的那个女人，你知道，30号洛克菲勒中心。
I said, yes, I was just speaking to a woman about my internship and we got disconnected. She said, oh, Barbara? I said, yes, Barbara. She said, let me transfer you. I said, thank you. Got to Barbara. Barbara was like, hi, Barbara. I was like, Barbara, I was just talking to someone about my internship and got disconnected.
我说，是的，我刚才在和一个女人谈我的实习，我们断线了。她说，哦，芭芭拉？我说，是的，芭芭拉。她说，让我帮你转接。我说，谢谢。转到了芭芭拉那里。芭芭拉说，嗨，芭芭拉。我说，芭芭拉，我刚才在和某人谈我的实习，然后断线了。
And she was like, oh, were you talking to Nancy? I was like, yes. I was talking to Nancy. Transfer me through to Nancy. Nancy answers hello. I'm like, hi, I was talking to someone about my internship. And she goes, how did you get my number? Did you tell her? I told her. I said, well, for three months I called and I got your voicemail. And no one called me back. So today, I called and I lied. And I said that I was talking to someone. And that person transferred me to Barbara. And then I told Barbara a version of that lie. And she transferred me to you. And did Nancy say you're hired? Nancy said, can you be here Monday?
她说，哦，你在和南希谈吗？我说，是的。我在和南希谈。帮我转接给南希。南希接听了，喂。我说，嗨，我刚才在和某人谈我的实习。她说，你是怎么得到我的号码的？你告诉她了吗？我告诉她了。我说，好吧，三个月来我一直打电话，我得到了你的语音信箱。没人给我回电。所以今天，我打了电话，我撒了谎。我说我在和某人谈。那个人把我转接给了芭芭拉。然后我告诉了芭芭拉那个谎言的一个版本。她把我转接给了你。南希说你被录用了吗？南希说，你周一能来吗？
And I was in Texas. It was a Friday. I was in Archer City, Texas, very rural area, three hours from a big airport. I said, sure thing. What time? She said, I'll see you Monday at 9. I said, great. I got off the phone.
当时我在德克萨斯州。那是周五。我在德克萨斯州的阿彻城，非常偏远的地区，离大机场有三个小时的路程。我说，当然。几点？她说，周一9点见。我说，太好了。我挂了电话。
I said, Mom, Dad, I got to go to New York. Lady, that is what it takes. That's what it takes. I think you just like, when you're starting out, and especially when you're like the lowest person on the totem pole, you got to have a little hustle. Got to have a little hustle. Guys, you heard it from us. Get that hustle.
我说，妈，爸，我得去纽约。女士，这就是代价。这就是代价。我觉得你只是，当你刚开始的时候，尤其是当你处于社会底层时，你必须有一点拼劲。必须有一点拼劲。伙计们，你们从我们这里听到了。去拼吧。
Okay. So there is a whole bunch of deleted scenes with Kelly in accounting. There's like a whole runner. It's really fun. I mean, at one point, Kelly and Angela get into this huge fight. And Kelly says, you look old enough to be my mother. And Angela then calls her a slut. Oh, my gosh.
好吧。所以凯利在会计部有很多删减片段。有一个完整的情节线。真的很有趣。我是说，有一次，凯利和安吉拉大吵了一架。凯利说，你看上去老得可以当我妈了。然后安吉拉叫她荡妇。天哪。
I know. And then they make up, Kelly apologizes. And then she's like, oh, my God, we're best friends. And Angela's like, I don't know about that. It's like, but there's a whole other journey that Kelly and Angela have that you don't see. Well, now should we go into the car with Andy and Jim driving to the high school? Yes. Is this it, Angela?
我知道。然后她们和好了，凯利道歉了。然后她说，哦，天哪，我们是最好的朋友。安吉拉说，我不知道是不是这样。就像是，但凯利和安吉拉还有一段你没看到的完整旅程。好吧，现在我们应该去安迪和吉姆开车去高中的车里吗？是的。是这个吗，安吉拉？
This is leading up to it. Here are some things we learn on this road trip with Jim and Andy. Number one, we learn that Andy says, beer me when he wants something. Beer is like a verb. Like, get me that. Beer me that water, right? Yes. We also learned that Karen is one of Andy's oldest friends. Hmm? What? I think that's just because they worked together at Stanford. Yeah. Yeah. And we learned that do not ask Andy to play music. Because he just sings. Like some acapella version of Drift Away. Well, this beer me line is another one of our most quoted. And Jim even says, Lord Bill beer me the strength. That's my favorite line. That's yours. Of almost like, I think about lines from the whole entire show. And one of my favorite lines from the whole entire series happens at seven
这正引向那一幕。这是我们在吉姆和安迪的公路旅行中学到的一些事情。第一，我们了解到安迪想要什么东西时会说“啤酒我”。啤酒就像一个动词。就像，给我那个。把那瓶水啤酒我，对吧？是的。我们还了解到凯伦是安迪的老朋友之一。嗯？什么？我想那只是因为他们在斯坦福一起工作过。是的。是的。而且我们了解到不要让安迪放音乐。因为他只会唱歌。就像某种阿卡贝拉版本的《漂流而去》。好吧，这句“啤酒我”是我们被引用最多的台词之一。吉姆甚至说，“主啊，啤酒我力量。”那是我最喜欢的台词。那是你的。几乎就像，我想起整个剧中的台词。我最喜欢的整个系列中的台词之一发生在7分51秒，是“主啊，啤酒我力量”。我太喜欢它了。我不知道是不是因为成长过程中，有很多次我像是在说，主啊，给我力量。是的。而只是有“主啊，啤酒我力量”。而只是有“主啊，啤酒我力量”。它只是让我发痒。我就是喜欢它。好吧，我联系了贾斯汀和布伦特，因为我很好奇是谁写了这个“啤酒我”的笑话。哦，我很想知道。好吧。他们告诉我，他们的记忆是埃德·赫尔姆斯在大学里有个朋友过去常说“啤酒我”。是布伦特扩展了它并写了这个笑话，“啤酒我一瓶水”。但这基于埃德·赫尔姆斯的一个故事。他们说他也有这个朋友会做那种“rit-da-to-do”。
minutes, 51 seconds, and it's Lord Fear Me Strength. I love it so much. I don't know if it's because growing up, there's been so many times where I've been like, Lord, give me strength. Yeah. And just to have Lord, bear me strength. And just to have Lord bear me strength. It just tickles me. I just love it. Well, I reached out to Justin and Brent because I was very curious who wrote this beer me joke. Oh, I would love to know. All right. They told me that their memory is that Ed Helms had a friend in college who used to say beer me. And it was Brent who expanded it and wrote the joke, Beer Me a Water. But this was based on a story from Ed Helms. they said he also had this friend that would do the rit-da-to-do.
埃德证实了这一点，对吧？埃德说他有个朋友会做那种胡言乱语来打断别人。是的。好吧。好吧，我给埃德发了短信，埃德说，我不知道他们在说什么。我不记得有什么朋友。他说，是的，他们有那个“rid-ed-a-to-do”，但我完全不记得有朋友说“啤酒我”。
And Ed confirmed that, right? Ed said he had a friend who would do like a gibberish thing to cut people off. Yeah. All right. Well, I texted Ed, and Ed is like, I don't know what they're talking about. I don't have any memory of a friend. He was like, yeah, they're rid-ed-a-to-do, but I have no memory of a friend saying, beer me.
我不知道。天哪。这就像那一刻，你知道，某事发生了，你问五个人发生了什么，他们每个人都有不同的故事。是的。是的。哦，天哪。我们知道的一件事是布伦特确实写了“啤酒我一瓶水”这个笑话。所以吉姆算是忍受了这次和安迪的车程。现在他们在高中，他们走进去，安迪说，哦，天哪，我女朋友在这里干什么？吉姆说，哦，她是辅导员之类的吗？他说，不，她在冷冻酸奶店做兼职。是的。她是那个女孩。
I don't know. Oh, my gosh. This is like that moment where, you know, something happens and you ask five people what happen and they all have a different story. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, man. The one thing we know is that Brent did write the joke, Beer Me a Water. So Jim has sort of suffered through this car ride with Andy. Now they're in the high school and they're walking through and Andy's like, oh my God, what's my girlfriend doing here? And Jim's like, oh, is she like the counselor or something? And he's like, no, she works part time at the frozen yogurt place. Yeah. She's that girl.
在她的储物柜旁。她的储物柜。是的。吉姆说，哦，安迪。哦，天哪。所以安迪走过去质问她，她说，我得去上西班牙语课。安迪惊呆了。他根本不知道她是高中生。
by her locker. Her locker. Yeah. And Jim's like, oh, Andy. Oh, Lord. So Andy goes up to confront her, and she's like, I have to go to Spanish class. Andy's mind is blown. He had no idea that she was a high school student.
安迪确实让我们知道他们没有做任何违法的事情，除了和她的朋友们推倒了几个邮箱。还有一个删减片段，安迪在采访镜头中谈到他们是如何相遇的。他在一家便利店，她让他为她和她的朋友们买葡萄酒冷却器。哦，天哪。好吧，饰演杰米的演员是希拉·斯科特·阿斯特罗夫，女士，她是《单身汉》第16季的参赛者。就是本的那一季，单身汉本。我不知道，我从没看过《单身汉》。好吧，她是单身汉国度的一员。
Andy does let us know that they did not do anything illegal except knock over a few mailboxes with her friends. There's also a deleted scene where Andy talks about how they met in a talking head. and he was at like a convenience store and she asked him to buy wine coolers for her and her friends. Oh, boy. Well, the actress who played Jamie was Shira Scott Astroff and Lady, she was a contestant on The Bachelor Season 16. The one with Ben, Bachelor Ben. I don't, I've never watched The Bachelor. Okay, well, she's part of Bachelor Nation.
所以我去Ins上查了她，然后滑进了她的私信。天哪。她说什么？好吧，首先，希拉和我有一个共同的朋友。是演员迈克尔·罗森鲍姆。所以我滑进她私信时感觉没那么诡异，因为我在她的Ins上看到她是迈克尔的朋友。所以我能以此为切入点。那很好。
So I looked her up on Insta and I slid into her DMs. Oh my gosh. What'd she say? Okay, well, first of all, Shira and I have a mutual friend in common. And it's actor Michael Rosenbaum. So I think it was slightly less creepy when I slid into her DMs because I saw on her Insta that she was friends with Michael. So I was able to lead with that. That's good.
是的。我总是试图找到滑进别人私信的最不诡异的方式。嘿，那是谁？嘿，还记得你上过《办公室》吗？你想谈谈吗？我有一阵子没和他说话了，但那是谁？好吧。好吧，所以我们给她发了邮件。
Yeah. I'm always trying to find the least creepy way to slide into someone's DMs. Hey, what's that? Hey, remember when you were on the office? You want to talk about it? I haven't talked to him a while, but what's that? Okay. Okay, so we emailed her.
她回信了，她告诉我所有关于她在节目中的时光。因为，安吉，每当这些场景发生在某个地点而我们不在场时，我喜欢了解细节。我想了解一点。不，我喜欢。每次我们联系到像这样场景中的某个人，总是非常有趣，它只是为我们填补了画面。好吧，这是她告诉我的。
She emailed back, and she told me all about her time on the show. Because, Ange, whenever there are these scenes that happen on a location and we weren't there, I like to get details. I want to know a little bit about it. No, I love it. Every time we reach out to someone in scenes like this, it's always so fun and it just kind of fills in the picture for us. All right, so here is what she told me.
她说当她得到这个试镜时，她以前从没看过这个节目。真的吗？是的。所以她说她看了一集，然后去试镜。那是冷读，意味着他们不会提前给她材料，因为他们不想让剧情泄露。哦，那太难了。所以她一无所知。但后来她得到了这份工作。
She said that when she got the audition for this, she had never watched the show before. Really? Yeah. So she said she watched one episode and then went to her audition. It was a cold read, meaning they would not give her the material ahead of time because they didn't want the storyline to leak. Oh, that's so hard. So she had no idea. But then she got the job.
而且她还告诉我，因为她从没真正看过这个节目，她以为她要扮演迈克尔的女朋友。所以当她到片场时，她期待看到史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，那时她遇到了埃德和约翰。现在，这是我发现绝对迷人的一点。在这一集中，当她拍摄这一幕时，她离28岁生日还有三个月。
And also she told me because she had never really watched the show, she thought that she was going to be playing. Michael's girlfriend. So when she got to set, she was expecting to see Steve Carell, and that's when she met Ed and John. Now, here is the thing that I found absolutely fascinating. In this episode, when she shot this, she was three months shy from turning 28.
天哪。她27岁。她说她比约翰·卡拉辛斯基大，只比埃德·赫尔姆斯小五岁。娃娃脸。哦，天哪。她说她拍摄这一集度过了绝对最美好的时光。这仍然是她经历过的最好的体验之一。
Oh, my gosh. She was 27 years old. She said she was older than John Krasinski and only five years younger than Ed Helms. Babyface. Oh, my goodness. She said she had the absolute best time filming this episode. It is still one of the best experiences she's ever had.
拍摄结束后，她回家看了每一集《办公室》第一季。她完全刷完了。所以当她的那一集最终播出时，她超级兴奋。她就像个超级粉丝。那太有趣了。但她说直到今天，人们仍然写信给她关于上节目的事。她很自豪地说她是《办公室》的一员。好吧，听着，伙计们，希拉告诉我们她在《办公室》的时光真是太可爱了。她有一部新
And after she filmed it, she went home and watched every single office episode from season one. She totally binged it. And so she was super excited by the time her episode finally aired. She was like a super fan. That is so fun. But she said to this day, people still write her about being on the show. And she's so proud to say that she was part of her. the office. Well, listen, guys, Shira was so lovely to tell us about her time on the office. She has a new
电影要上映了，叫《半个兄弟》。她还将出演亚马逊的一部试播集，叫《在光谱上》。她的Instagram是@ShiraScottAstroff，但这是我迫不及待要给的插件。她是动物救援组织“动物救援使命”的创始人。他们在洛杉矶和世界各地救援受虐待和被忽视的狗和猫，她刚刚从蒂华纳的死囚牢房救了70只狗。天哪。并把它们安置在家里。所以她说如果有人想领养动物或捐款，你可以去“动物救援使命”看看。我喜欢那个。我们有四个救援动物。我喜欢小救援动物。这让我很高兴。我知道。我们应该谈谈德怀特为办公室的大型新闻发布会做准备吗？哦，是的。嗯，你知道，他把这等同于甜菜销售。你必须把钱甜菜放出来。那些是有吸引力的甜菜。你必须把它们放在前面。没错。他为一场大型新闻发布会布置了会议室，全是为了一个人。
film coming out called Half Brothers. She's also going to be in a pilot on Amazon called On the Spectrum. Her Instagram is at Shira Scott Astroff, but here's the plug I can't wait to give. She is the founder of an animal rescue organization called the Animal Rescue Mission. They rescue abused and neglected dogs and cats in Los Angeles and all over the world, she just rescued like 70 dogs from death row in Tijuana. Oh my gosh. And placed them in homes. So she said if anyone wants to adopt an animal or donate, you can go to the animal
这是来自《斯克兰顿时报》的查德·莱特。他负责生活轻松的一面。是的。还有讣告。没错。有一个很棒的删减片段是他和克里德，他认出了克里德。他说，等等，来自草根乐队的克里德·布拉顿。珍娜，他基本上把克里德当成了他自己。
rescue mission and check them out. I love that. We have four rescues. I love little rescue animals. That makes me so happy. I know. Should we talk about Dwight preparing for the big press conference back at the office? Oh, yeah. Well, you know, he equates this to beat sales. You got to put the money beats. Those are the attractive beats. You got to put them up front. That's right. He has set up the conference room for a giant press conference, all for one man.
天哪。而且它又被删了。克里德的起源不断被删除。它在《酒船》中被删了，它在……我们发现他从监狱里的人那里偷了名字的那一集，也就是《罪犯》中被删了。现在又一次。所以查德·莱特说，来自草根乐队的克里德·布拉顿。克里德说，是的。
This is Chad Light from the Scrant Times. He does the lighter side of life. Yeah. And the obits. Right. And there's a great deleted scene with him and Creed where he recognizes Creed. He's like, wait, Creed Bratton from the grassroots. Jenna, he basically calls Creed out as himself.
他说，我写了你的讣告。克里德说，哦，是的。克里德有一个很棒的采访镜头，他伪造了自己的死亡，这样他就能得到保险索赔之类的东西。他得到了钱。所以是的。太棒了。太棒了。好吧，查德·莱特由安东尼·拉塞尔饰演。
Oh my gosh. And it got deleted again. The origin of Creed keeps getting deleted. It got deleted out of Booz Cruz. It got deleted out of what was the other episode where we found out that he stole his name from someone in prison, the convict. And now again. So Chad Light goes, Creed Bratton from the grassroots. And Creed's like, yeah.
我在安东尼的简历中发现了这一点，我觉得这绝对非常迷人。上面写着，小时候他演奏口琴、尤克里里、吉他、长号和钢琴。他通过在乐队唱歌来完成大学学业。在从蒙特克莱尔州立学院毕业并主修长号、辅修钢琴后，他的乐队被预订为许多大型酒店的拉斯维加斯休息室表演。好吧，我演奏过长号。什么？不，你没有。哦，是的，呃，别说了，你在说什么？是的，当我们搬到阿彻城时
And he goes, I wrote your obituary. And Creed was like, oh, yeah. Creed has this great talking head that he faked his death so he could get like an insurance claim or something. He gets money. And so yeah. Amazing. Amazing. Well, Chad Light was played by Anthony Russell.
那是一个非常小的城镇，就像在橄榄球中，那是2a级，超级小的城镇，所以要有一个行进乐队，几乎每个人都必须参加，所以我的所有朋友，那个城镇，你知道，我毕业时只有34个人，所以我的朋友查南说，你要在乐队里演奏吗？我说，我不知道怎么演奏乐器。她说，没关系，我们只是看起来像是在演奏。所以我说，好吧，你演奏什么？现在，我最好的朋友身高6英尺3英寸，伙计们。她就像是明星篮球运动员。我说，你演奏什么？
And I found this in Anthony's bio, which I thought was absolutely. So charming. It said, as a child, he played harmonica, ukulele, guitar, trombone, and piano. He worked his way through college singing in a show band. And after he graduated Montclair State College with a major in trombone and a minor in piano, his band was booked as a Las Vegas lounge act for many major hotels. Well, I played the trombone. What? no you did not oh yeah uh stop it what are you talking about yeah when we moved to archer city
她说，我演奏长号。我当时身高4英尺10英寸。我说，是的，好吧，听起来不错。我会做你正在做的事情，因为我想坐在她旁边。长号组只有三个人，香农、比尔·克鲁彻和我。我说，第一天我坐在比尔旁边，我说，比尔，你演奏什么？因为我能听到的只有，br-，他说，我只是演奏字母F。我说，好吧。所以香农是唯一一个真正会演奏的人，但我确实学会了
it's a very small town like in football it was class 2a super small town so to have a marching band pretty much everyone had to participate and so all my friends the the town was you know i graduated with like 34 people so my friend chanan was like are you going to play in the band and i was like i don't know how to play an instrument she goes it doesn't really matter we just seen people And so I was like, well, what do you play? Now, my best friend was six foot three, guys. She was like the star basketball player. I said, what do you play?
演奏《龙舌兰》。那是？巴拿-拿-拿-拿-拿-拿-拿-拿-拿。是的，我学会了演奏那个。在长号上演奏真的很有趣，因为你可以，你做这个大滑音，然后我永远够不到最后一个位置，你知道，第七位置，因为我太矮了。我的手臂伸展不开。珍娜，你不会用计算器算年份的。我生命中有几个月在乐队里演奏长号。顺便说一句，非常糟糕，非常糟糕地演奏长号。我无语了。我不知道。我们在哪？哦，天哪。我不知道还有没有人听了。好吧，听着，我告诉你我们在哪。查德·莱特获得了三级安全许可。
She said, I play trombone. I was like 4'10. I was like, yeah, okay, sounds good. I'll do what you're doing because I wanted to be able to sit next to her. There was only three people in the trombone section, Shannon, Bill Crutcher, and me. And I said, the first day I sat next to Bill, and I said, Bill, what are you playing? Because all I could hear was like, br- and he goes, I just play letter. F the whole time. I said, okay. So Shannon was the only one that could really play, but I did learn how
别兴奋。那是20级里的三级。他们正在为这个大型新闻发布会做准备。与此同时，凯文、奥斯卡和安吉拉正忙着向客户道歉，情况不太好。嗯，因为安吉拉拒绝说“我很抱歉”这几个字。她不会道歉。她一直说诸如“我们的官方立场是道歉”之类的话。她就像是，不会只是说我们非常抱歉。我喜欢当凯利耐心地试图指导她说话时，就像，只是为了进行对话。她说，你是哪里人？俄亥俄州，那很好。她只是不想和这些人说话。
to play tequila. What's that? Bana-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na. Yeah, I learned how to play that. It's really fun on the trombone because you can, you do this big slide, and then I could never reach the last position, you know, seventh position, because I was too short. My arms didn't extend. Jenna, you wouldn't use a calculator for the year. I was in a band playing a trombone for a few months of my life. Very poorly, by the way, very poorly playing the trombone. I'm speechless. I don't know. Where are we? Oh, God. I don't know if anyone even is listening anymore. Well, listen, I'll tell you where we are. Chad Light has gotten level three security clearance.
不，不。而且，顺便说一句，与此同时，克里德发现黛比·布朗上周没来上班。他为德怀特编造了一个完整的故事。他说，嗯，现在她告诉我她有一个紧急牙医预约。德怀特向镜头看了一眼，我认为这有点呼应了他对迈克尔撒谎说他有牙医预约。记得克伦蒂斯，那个牙医吗？是的。
Don't get excited. It's level three out of 20. And they're getting ready for this big press conference. Meanwhile, Kevin Oscar and Angela are busy apologizing to customers, and it is not going well. Well, because Angela refuses to say the words, I'm sorry. She will not apologize. She keeps saying things like, our official position is one of apology. She's like, will not just say we are so sorry. I love it when, like, Kelly is just patiently trying to coach her to say, like, just to make conversation. And she's like, where are you from? Ohio, that's nice. She just does not want to be talking to these people.
但后来他说，嗯，然后黛比告诉她工作的人她得了胃流感。所以她显然只是在编造事情来避免为这个水印承担责任。他真的在夸大其词。克里德很恶毒。是的。好吧，艾伦小姐到了。在我们进入这个非常尴尬的新闻发布会之前，我们为什么不休息一下。是的，在我们进入这个之前我们需要一点时间。我们保证我们只会谈论
No, no. And also, by the way, in the meantime, Creed has found out that Debbie Brown did not show up to work last week. And he spins a whole tale for Dwight. He says, well, now she told me that she had an emergency dentist appointment. And Dwight gives a look to camera, which I think. is a little bit of a callback to his lie to Michael about his dentist appointment. Remember, Krentiss, the dentist? Yes.
《办公室》剩下的节目。当我们知道这不是真的时，你为什么要保证那个？哦。我们会尝试的。我们会尝试的。我们会尝试的。道明银行知道经营一家小企业是一段旅程，从创业到成长和管理你的业务。这就是为什么他们在网站上有一个专门的小企业建议中心。为企业家提供商业银行方面的提示和见解，无论你处于业务的哪个阶段。访问TD.com/smallbusinessadvice了解更多信息，或与道明小企业银行客户经理匹配。好吧。所以我们回来了。我们专注于激光。我们正在参加新闻发布会。哦，情况不太好。不。
But then he says, well, then Debbie told the people at her work that she had the stomach flu. So she's clearly just making things up to avoid taking responsibility for this watermark. He's really laying it on thick. Creed is vicious. Yeah. Well, Miss Allen arrives. And before we get into this really embarrassing press conference, why don't we take a break. Yeah, we need a moment before we get to this. We promise we're going to just talk about
迈克尔向艾伦夫人道歉，他给了她一张巨大的证书，你知道他很喜欢。记得在《赌场之夜》，他说，托比，我们要有那些巨大的支票吗？他太，我是说。他称之为新奇支票。这是一张新奇支票。它很大，巨大。上面写着六个月免费纸张或25令，以先到者为准。艾伦夫人不接受道歉。
the office for the rest of the show. Why would you promise that when we know it's not true? Oh. We'll try. We'll try. We'll try. Td Bank knows that running a small business is a journey, from startup to growing and managing your business. That's why they have a dedicated small business advice hub on their website. provide tips and insights on business banking to entrepreneurs, no matter the stage of business you're in. Visit TD.com slash small business advice to find out more or to match with a TD small business banking account manager. All right. So we are back. We are laser focused. And we are in a press conference. Oh, it is not going well. No.
艾伦夫人给了零个F，正如孩子们所说。哦，是的。她字面上说，我不接受你的道歉。太棒了。迈克尔不知道该怎么办。而且，你知道，查德在后面记下了关于这次新闻发布会的所有笔记。他准备写他的文章。哦，他的手在那个记事本上飞快地移动。他把一切都记下来了。所以艾伦夫人和迈克尔之间的这种来回，它只是开始升级。然后他只是让她离开，她就冲了出去，说她要给商业改进局打电话。迈克尔说，哦，是的，好吧，我要给忘恩负义的碧池热线打电话。它真的，真的没有按计划进行。我是说，我不认为有任何其他方式可以表达它。我不知道它还能更糟。我真的不知道。好吧，女士，艾伦夫人，那个把艾伦夫人演得这么好的女人，是丽莎·达尔，她做了很多事情，比如《抑制热情》。她是《我们所知道的生活》和《流行》的常客。她还在《强力药物》中担任常驻角色，那是我有单日客串角色的节目，当时我的大脑融化了。但我发现这非常迷人，因为我最终深入研究了她的IMDB页面。这太疯狂了。你准备好了吗？是的。
Michael apologizes to Mrs. Allen, and he offers her a giant certificate, which you know he loves. Remember in Casino Night, he was like, Toby, are we going to have one of those giant checks? He's so, I mean. It's a novelty check is what he calls it. It's a novelty check. It's big, huge. It says six free months of paper or 25 reams, whichever comes first. And Mrs. Allen does not accept the apology.
她出现在三集《女作家与谋杀案》中，但每一集都在不同的季节，她扮演不同的角色。然后她在两个不同的季节扮演了两个不同角色的《犯罪现场调查》。所以她是一位如此优秀的演员，以至于她可以在同一部电视剧中多次出现，每次都扮演不同的角色。我觉得这非常能说明她的才华。是的，但也会，她会改变她的外表吗？我不知道，因为我没有做那么深入的研究。我没有像YouTube那样看她所有的出场，但我是说，我发现这很有意义。
Mrs. Allen gives zero Fs, as the kids say. Oh, yeah. She literally says, I do not accept your apology. It's so good. Michael doesn't know what to do with it. And, you know, Chad is back there taking up all the notes on this press conference. He's ready to write his article. Oh, his hand is flying across that notepad. He's jotting everything down. So this back and forth between Mrs. Allen and Michael, it just starts to escalate. And then he just asked her to leave and she just storms out and says she's going to call the Better Business Bureau. And Michael's like, oh, yeah, well, I'm going to call the ungrateful Biatch hotline. It really, really did not go as planned. I mean, I don't think there's any other way to say it. I don't know it could have gone worse. I really don't. Well, lady, Mrs. Allen, the woman who played Mrs. Allen so very well, was Lisa Dar, and she has done a ton of stuff like Curb Your Enthusiasm. She was a regular on Life as We Know It and popular. She also had a recurring on strong medicine, which is the show that I had a one-day guest role on where my brain melted. But I found this very fascinating because I ended up doing a deep dive on her IMDB page. This is crazy. Are you ready? Yes.
是的。而且不寻常。是的，除非，我觉得这在过去发生得更多，比如在《神仙家庭》中。不是有两个达伦吗，而且，就像，从来没有解释过之类的？好吧，那就像是一个主要角色的改变。这就像是一个客串角色，对吧？但他们雇佣了同一个演员在三个不同的客串角色中。他们爱她。
She appeared in three episodes of murder she wrote, but each episode was in a different season and she played a different character. And then she was in two different seasons playing two different characters of CSI. So she is such a good actress that she can appear multiple times in the same television show playing a different character each time. I felt like that was very telling of her talent. It is, but also, would she change her look? I don't know because I didn't do that deep of a dive. I didn't like YouTube all of her appearances, but I mean, I found that significant.
显然。显然。好吧，我爱她。我觉得她在我们的节目中很棒。她太好了。她真的只是，我是说，把迈克尔推向了边缘。天哪。你知道，珍娜，我确实说过什么会让这次新闻发布会更糟。
Yeah. And unusual. Yeah, unless, I feel like that happened more back in the day, like on Bewitched. Weren't there two Darren's and, like, it was never explained or something? Well, that's like a major character change. This is like a guest role, right? But they hired the same actress in three different guest roles. They loved her.
而德怀特，再一次，没有帮助。他说他认为两只动物都在笑。有一个很棒的德怀特采访镜头，他谈到在农场长大，他见过很多动物动作，他说得非常实事求是，画这个的人完全画对了。是的，他试图告诉艾伦夫人，卡通似乎确实描绘了一种双方同意的性行为，因为它们在笑。德怀特会知道，因为他的农场生活。没错。好吧，迈克尔真的很沮丧。他开始向帕姆发泄。
Clearly. Clearly. Well, I loved her. I thought she was great on our show. She was so good. And she really just, I mean, push Michael over the edge. Oh, my gosh. You know, Jen, I did say what could have made this press conference worse.
我是说，事情失控了。这将是一个全国性的故事。她说，迈克尔，这是《斯克兰顿时报》。他说，不，我们需要做一个道歉视频。好吧，然后迈克尔拿出了摄像机。珍娜，你作为帕姆的表情太精彩了。太精彩了，珍娜。它说了太多的历史。
And Dwight, once again, does not help. He says he thought both animals were smiling. There is a fantastic Dwight talking head where he talks about growing up on a farm, and he has seen a lot of animal action, and he says really matter-of-factly, whoever drew this got it exactly right. Yeah, he tries to tell Mrs. Allen that the cartoon did seem to depict a consensual sex act because they were smiling. And Dwight would know because of his farm life. Right. Well, Michael is really upset. He starts to vent to Pam.
帕姆不得不拍摄多少迈克尔的视频？为事情道歉。我会告诉你，在删减片段中，有一个视频的跑步者，它们太棒了。我正要说，我们拍摄了一大堆以前的道歉视频，它们没有进入这一集。我会告诉你，和史蒂夫和雷恩拍摄这一幕，然后还有这些旧的道歉视频，是我在节目中经历过的最有趣的事情之一。很难完成这些。太难了。我不知道你是怎么做到的。
I mean, that things got out of control. It's going to be a national story. She's like, Michael, this is the Scranton Times. And he's like, no, we need to do an apology video. Well, then Michael pulls out the video camera. And Jenna, the look on your face is Pam is so brilliant. It's so brilliant, Jenna. It said so much history.
关于你的表情的一切，珍娜，都是完美。你没有透露太多，但它说明了很多关于帕姆在想什么。我只是觉得你做了一项非凡的工作。我喜欢这些场景。我喜欢看删减的那些。我想看更多。我可以看到你们必须做的所有这些视频的剪辑秀。而且我喜欢小细节。
How many videos has Pam had to film of Michael? apologizing for things. I will tell you in the deleted scenes, there's a runner of videos and they're fantastic. I was going to say that, that we shot a whole bunch of former apology videos and they didn't make it in the episode. I will tell you that shooting this scene with Steve and Rain and then also these old apology videos is some of the most fun I ever had on the show. It was so hard to get through these. It was so difficult. I don't know how you did it.
喜欢他身后的美国国旗，显然是用四张纸粘在一起做的。是的。而且我喜欢从15分55秒到16分05秒，德怀特，只是在喷迈克尔的头发。是的。11秒的沉默，除了。是的。好吧，他喷了头发。我无法完成那个。
And everything about your expressions, Jenna, are perfection. You don't give away much, but it says so much about what Pam is thinking. I just thought you did a phenomenal job. And I loved these scenes. I love seeing the deleted ones. I want to see more. I could just see a clip show of all these videos that you guys had to do. And I love the small touches.
我笑得太厉害了。我不断地崩溃。完成那个非常，非常困难。当你想到节目的房地产时，就像每一个小时刻都很重要，你试图尽可能多地塞进去。我喜欢我们的节目会采取这样的节拍。11秒，没人说一句话，只是一个气溶胶罐。比你必须在公牛身上待的时间还长。那是真的。
love the American flag behind him, clearly made out of four pieces of paper taped together. Yep. And I loved that from 15 minutes, 55 seconds to 16 minutes, five seconds, Dwight, it's just spraying Michael's hair. Yeah. 11 seconds of silence except for. Yeah. Well, he sprays the hair. I couldn't get through that.
谢谢你把我的时间测量带回公牛骑行。好吧，另外，我不知道你是否注意到在这一幕中，我保持着对镜头的注视。我从来没有抬头看史蒂夫。我这样做有两个原因。第一，因为这感觉就像我负责操作摄像机。所以我确保他保持在框架内。这看起来就像是我的工作。但另一个原因是，因为我可以看着那个小塑料角，然后我就不会
I laughed so hard. I broke constantly. It was very, very difficult to get through that. When you think about the real estate of a show, like every little moment counts, you're trying to just jam it with as much as possible. And I loved that our show would take these beats like this. 11 seconds, no one's saying a word, just an aerosol can. Longer than you have to stay on a bull. That's true.
不得不真正看到史蒂夫，而且我更容易不笑。我对此感到好奇。我当时想，A，看起来你真的在操作摄像机，但你有多幸运，你不需要眼神接触？因为你会笑得前仰后合。另外，当雷恩掉落其中一张提示卡并在地上发出砰的一声时，那让我笑了。就像我在重看这一幕时，我不断地崩溃。那些可怜的家伙，我是说，他们一定在想，珍娜，你需要离开房间。好吧，有一个删减片段，你知道，迈克尔做了第一个视频，他对它不满意，对吧？好吧，在删减片段中，珍娜，有他拍摄视频的第二个版本。你知道，你们拍了第一个。是的，他不喜欢它。
Thank you for bringing my measurement of time back to bull riding. Well, also, I don't know if you noticed in this scene, I kept my gaze on the camera. I never looked up to Steve. And I did this for two reasons. One, because it just felt like I'm in charge of operating the camera. And so I was going to make sure he stayed in frame. And that just seemed like sort of my job. But the other reason was because I could look at the little plastic corner and then I wouldn't
谢谢你把我的时间衡量标准拉回到骑牛比赛上。嗯，还有，我不知道你有没有注意到那一幕，我的目光一直盯着摄像机。我从来没有抬头看史蒂夫。我这样做有两个原因。第一，因为我觉得自己负责操作摄像机。所以我得确保他一直在画面里。这似乎就是我的工作。但另一个原因是，因为我可以盯着那个塑料小角落，这样我就不必真的看到史蒂夫，不笑场对我来说更容易些。
have to actually see Steve, and it was easier for me not to laugh. I wondered about that. I was like, A, it looks like you're really operating a video camera, but how lucky were you that you didn't have to make eye contact? Because you would have burst into laughter. Also, when rain drops one of the cue cards and it makes a thud on the ground, that made me laugh. It was like when I was rewatching the scene, just I was breaking constantly. Those poor guys, I mean, they must have been like, Jenna, you need to leave the room. Well, there is a deleted scene of, you know, Michael does the first video and he's not happy with it, right? Well, in the deleted scenes, Jenna, there is his second take at the video. You know, you guys shoot the first one. Yeah, and he doesn't like it.
我当时就在想这个问题。我在想，首先，你看上去真的很像在操作摄像机，但你不用和他进行眼神交流，这得有多幸运啊？因为你肯定会笑喷的。还有，当瑞恩掉落其中一张提示卡，发出砰的一声时，那让我笑了。重看那一幕时，我一直在笑场。那些可怜的家伙，他们肯定在想，珍娜，你得离开这个房间。嗯，有一个删减片段，你知道，迈克尔拍了第一个视频，但他不满意，对吧？嗯，在删减片段里，珍娜，那是他拍的第二个版本。你知道，你们拍了第一个。是的，但他不喜欢。
He doesn't like it. And there's a deleted scene. And Jen, I made me laugh so hard. Michael goes on to say, I need this job. My mortgage is hundreds of dollars a month. With this job, I can barely cover that. I have a company car, but I still have to pay for the gas. Gas prices are high. And I have no savings whatsoever. Oh, Michael. What's kind of fun for those folks who like to catch things on the background is that deleted scene dialogue is on the Q card. And their second attempt is right there. You can zoom in and see it. Yeah, a lot of people wrote in to ask, how come what Michael is saying isn't what is printed on the Q cards when they go back and forth? It was just because we cut some stuff out. We trimmed out some stuff. Yeah, he actually said everything that was on the cards. We just had to lose some of it for time.
他不喜欢。而且有一个删减片段。Jen，这让我笑得不行。Michael接着说，我需要这份工作。我的房贷每个月要几百美元。有了这份工作，我勉强能支付。我有公司配车，但我还得自己付油费。油价很高。而且我一点积蓄都没有。噢，Michael。对于那些喜欢在背景里找细节的人来说，有趣的是，那个删减片段的台词就在提示卡上。他们的第二次尝试就在那里。你可以放大看。是的，很多人写信来问，为什么Michael说的和他们来回走动时提示卡上印的不一样？那只是因为我们剪掉了一些东西。我们删减了一些内容。是的，他实际上说了卡片上的所有内容。我们只是为了时间不得不删掉一些。
Yeah. Well, over an accounting, we had someone write in. Megan Allman said, 17 minutes, six seconds, Kevin Sass. Yeah. Serious, Kevin Sass. Like, he's been holding it in for so long. He just couldn't wait, and now he's got something on her. Yeah.
是的。嗯，在会计部，有人写信来。Megan Allman说，17分06秒，Kevin Sass。是的。认真的，Kevin Sass。就像，他憋了太久了。他简直等不及了，现在他抓住了她的把柄。是的。
Angela is critiquing Kevin's math skills, and he then gives some sass by insulting your customer relations skills. Yeah, and then I call them apes, and then Oscar's like, apologize for that. And I'm like, oh, I'm sorry, you're both morons. And they're like, but you said sorry. It's like, it's like I'm sitting with my two, like, junior high brothers. Yeah. That's what they're like.
Angela在批评Kevin的数学能力，然后他通过侮辱你的客户关系技巧进行反击。是的，然后我叫他们猿猴，Oscar就说，为那个道歉。我说，噢，对不起，你们两个都是白痴。他们说，但你说了对不起。就像，就像我和我两个初中生弟弟坐在一起一样。是的。他们就是那样。
And I want you to know that Brian and Oscar improvised their sort of little high five at the end and that they, they don't quite get it right. They were so tickled by that moment. They, they kept cracking up. Brian kept cracking up. I love that. They had, they like did a few different tries at it. And it just was like their favorite thing. Okay.
我想让你知道，Brian和Oscar最后那个小小的击掌是即兴发挥的，而且他们没完全对上。他们被那一刻逗乐了。他们一直在笑。Brian一直在笑。我喜欢这个。他们尝试了几次。这简直是他们最喜欢的部分。好的。
Well, I loved that moment. moment. It made me laugh. Me too. Because why couldn't they have just high five? They were kind of doing like a coronavirus high five where you don't actually touch. And they were trying to do like a fist bum and air. But they're right there. They could have easily touched one another. But that's what it made me think of. I think they love the Jim Pam air high five. This is their dude version. Also, it would have meant that one of them would have had to get up or lean over awkwardly. And so I just They were like, eh. Oh, okay.
嗯，我喜欢那一刻。那一刻。它让我笑了。我也是。因为他们为什么不能直接击掌呢？他们当时做的就像是新冠时期的击掌，实际上并没有碰到。他们试图在空中碰拳。但他们就在那儿。他们本可以轻易地碰到对方。但这就是它让我想到的。我想他们喜欢Jim和Pam的空中击掌。这是他们的兄弟版。另外，这意味着他们中必须有一个人站起来或尴尬地探过身子。所以他们就，呃。噢，好的。
Well, I guess it was an optical illusion because it seemed like maybe they could have just made a connection. It would have required one of them getting up and neither of them. Okay. Neither them were up for it. Well, maybe we should go back to the high school for a second because we forgot to mention that Andy and Jim do meet with the principal. And it doesn't really go well because Andy is so. preoccupied by learning that his girlfriend is at the high school. Yeah, I don't really know.
嗯，我想那是个视觉错觉，因为看起来他们本可以建立联系。那需要他们中有一个人站起来，而他们谁都不愿意。好的。他们谁都不想。嗯，也许我们应该回到高中部，因为我们忘了提到Andy和Jim确实见了校长。而且进展并不顺利，因为Andy太专注于得知他的女朋友在高中了。是的，我不太清楚。
Did they get this account back? We don't know. It just seems like Andy's about to have a breakdown and Jim is just trying to get them out of there. Well, the principal was played by Jim Jansen, who also played Reverend Skinner on Gilmore Girls. A little bit of trivia. Ooh. Ooh, that is good trivia. I know.
他们拿回这个客户了吗？我们不知道。看起来Andy快要崩溃了，而Jim只是想带他们离开那里。嗯，校长是由Jim Jansen扮演的，他还在《吉尔莫女孩》中扮演了Skinner牧师。一点小花絮。噢。噢，那真是个好花絮。我知道。
And yeah, we don't really find out how that went. But as they're driving home in the car, Andy is still. clearly bummed out and Jim wants to cheer him up. I mean, Jim really, really goes for it here. He just starts going, oh, we, mo, a we, mo, a we, mo, a we, mo, a we, mo, and Andy's fighting it, he's fighting it, but then he just, he can't resist. He's like, ooh, like, he can't not jump in. Do you remember that time on the show when we all sang that in the bullpen? Was that for an episode, or were we just doing that one day? I think we just started doing it.
是的，我们确实不知道进展如何。但当他们开车回家时，Andy显然还是很沮丧，Jim想让他振作起来。我的意思是，Jim在这里真的很努力。他开始唱，噢，我们，莫，啊，我们，莫，啊，我们，莫，啊，我们，莫，啊，我们，莫，而Andy在抵抗，他在抵抗，但后来他忍不住了。他说，噢，就像，他无法不加入。你还记得剧里我们大家在办公室里一起唱那首歌的时候吗？那是为了某一集，还是我们那天只是随便唱唱？我想我们只是开始唱了。
Yeah, because it is kind of infectious when someone starts it. Yeah, we were just a little loopy. I think so, too. In the jungle, the quiet. Yeah. Oh, one last thing now, before we end this episode and get to this amazing tag is Creed. Yeah. Creed got this woman fired.
是的，因为当有人开始唱时，它确实很有感染力。是的，我们当时有点疯疯癫癫的。我也这么认为。在丛林里，安静。是的。噢，最后一件事，在我们结束这一集并进入这个精彩的片尾彩蛋之前，是Creed。是的。Creed让这个女人被解雇了。
and he's going around the office collecting money for her. He's going to put it in a card. You know, why do bad things always happen to good people, he asks. And then he tosses the card, he puts the money in his pocket, create his diabolical. Yeah. And we also find out that, in Pam's opinion, Michael made the best apology video ever. Yeah. That ended with an ultimatum.
他正在办公室里到处为她募捐。他要把钱放进卡片里。你知道，他问，为什么坏事总是发生在好人身上？然后他扔掉了卡片，把钱放进自己的口袋，Creed真是丧尽天良。是的。我们还发现，在Pam看来，Michael制作了有史以来最好的道歉视频。是的。以最后通牒结束的那个。
You have one day. What? Yeah. And where are these videos going, Jenna? Oh, they go nowhere. I'm pretty convinced that Pam never sends them anywhere. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
你有一天时间。什么？是的。Jenna，这些视频发到哪儿去了？噢，它们哪儿也没去。我非常确信Pam从来没有把它们发给任何人。噢，是的。噢，是的。
Well, now we have such a fun tag. And Rain had so much fun doing this. Yes. Dwight arrives for work the next day dressed as gym. But it backfires a little bit because everybody just compliments him on how great he looks. And he gets a little frustrated. And he tries to do like the gym look to camera. Yes.
嗯，现在我们有一个非常有趣的片尾彩蛋。Rain在做这个的时候玩得很开心。是的。Dwight第二天打扮成Jim来上班。但适得其反，因为每个人都夸他看起来很棒。他有点沮丧。他试图对着镜头模仿Jim的样子。是的。
But it's like so awkward. Yes. Well, I want to tell you that this was originally in the script as the alternate ending to the cold open. Dwight had a little talking head where he said to defeat your enemy, you have to become your enemy. And then he showed up to work dressed as gym, but in the editing process, we split it up, which I think was genius. I love that. I love that we end with it. I remember how much fun Rain had doing this scene, but I also remember him. talking with Randall, the director, about how Dwight couldn't be as good of a mimic as Jim. So whereas Jim could come in and just do this spot-on impression, they sort of felt like Dwight's version of Jim had to be a little messier, but like how do you thread that needle, right? Like how do you do an impression, but it's Dwight doing the impression? Because Rain could do an amazing impression of Jim Helper. but he had to do it as Dwight.
但这太尴尬了。是的。嗯，我想告诉你，这最初在剧本里是冷开场的备选结局。Dwight有一个小采访，他说要打败你的敌人，你必须成为你的敌人。然后他打扮成Jim来上班，但在剪辑过程中，我们把它分开了，我觉得这真是天才之举。我喜欢这个。我喜欢我们以它结尾。我记得Rain在拍这个场景时玩得有多开心，但我也记得他和导演Randall讨论Dwight不能像Jim那样擅长模仿。所以，虽然Jim可以进来做一个精准的模仿，但他们觉得Dwight版的Jim必须更笨拙一些，但你怎么把握那个度呢，对吧？就像你怎么做一个模仿，但那是Dwight在做模仿？因为Rain可以做一个很棒的Jim Halpert模仿，但他必须以Dwight的身份来做。
So I remember them playing with that a lot on the set when they were shooting this. Yeah, I feel like those moments would come up for us where it was like your character steps out of its comfort zone a little bit to do something, but you still have to do it as your character and through that filter. Yeah.
所以我记得他们在拍摄时在片场对此进行了很多尝试。是的，我觉得那些时刻会出现在我们身上，就像你的角色走出舒适区去做某事，但你仍然必须以你的角色身份并通过那个滤镜来做。是的。
But it was fun. It was fun for us to watch those fellows do that. Well, you guys, that was Product Recall. Thanks for taking that journey with us. We got off topic a few times, but. You know, there's some real nuggets in this. Lord, bear me strength. Oh, yes. And listen, identity theft is not a joke. Millions of families suffer every year. All right, guys. We'll see you next week. We'll see you next week.
但这很有趣。看着那些家伙那样做对我们来说很有趣。好吧，各位，这就是《产品召回》。感谢你们和我们一起踏上这段旅程。我们跑题了几次，但是。你知道，这里面有一些真正的干货。上帝，给我力量。噢，是的。还有，听着，身份盗窃不是开玩笑的。每年有数百万家庭受害。好了，伙计们。我们下周见。我们下周见。
Someone beer me a snack. I'm hungry. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jorkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
有人给我拿点零食。我饿了。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。这一集最初是与Earwolf合作制作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的一档节目，由Jenna Fisher和Angela Kinsey制作。我们的执行制片人是Cassie Jorkins，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是Molly Nugent。Odyssey的执行制片人是Leah Reese Dennis。《办公室女士》由Bill Schultz混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是Creed Bratton的《Rubber Tree》。
Thank you. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。